the following is a conversation with
john clark he's a friend
a brazilian jiu jitsu black belt former
mma fighter
and at least in my opinion one of the
great ufc cornerman coaches to listen to
and also he's my current jiu jitsu coach
at broadway jiu-jitsu in south boston
he was once for a time a philosophy
major in college
and is now i would say a kind of
practicing philosopher
opinionated brilliant and someone i
always enjoy talking to
even when especially when we disagree
which we do often he's definitely
someone i can see talking to many times
in this podcast
in fact he hosts a new podcast of his
own
called please allow me
quick mention of each sponsor followed
by some thoughts related to the episode
thank you to theragun the device i use
for post-workout muscle recovery
magic spoon carb keto friendly cereal
that i think is delicious
eight sleep a mattress that cools itself
and gives me yet another reason to enjoy
sleep
and cash app the app i use to send money
to friends
please check out these sponsors in the
description to get a discount and to
support this podcast
as a side note let me say that martial
arts especially jiu jitsu and judo
have been a big part of my growth as a
human being so i think i will
talk to a few martial artists on
occasion on this podcast
i hope that is of interest to you i
won't talk to people who are simply
great fighters or great athletes
but people who have a philosophy that i
find to be interesting and worth
exploring
even if i disagree with parts or most of
it
i like alternating between historians
and computer scientists
fighters and biologists and between
totally different worldviews
and personalities like elon musk and
michael malus
this world to me is fascinating
because of the diversity of weirdness
that is human civilization
i love the weird and the brilliant and
hope you join me on the journey of
exploring both
if you don't like an episode skip it for
an ocd person like myself
sometimes not listening to a podcast
episode is an act of courage
it's like not finishing a book even
though you're 80 done
try it sometimes listen to ones you like
and don't listen to the ones you don't
like i know
it's profound advice if you enjoy this
thing
subscribe on youtube review it with five
stars and apple podcast
follow on spotify support on patreon or
connect with me on twitter
and lex friedman and now here's my
conversation
with john clark you ready for this
i've been ready for this my whole life
all right i was thinking of doing a
kerouac style road trip across the
united states
you know after this whole covet thing
lifts you ever take a trip like that
i've done a handful of long distance
driving trips
um up and down the east coast but also
from the west coast back to the east
coast and then returning to california
so i've definitely done my fair share of
driving
in this country do you have the longing
for the great american road trip
i think there are so many things that
i've been lucky enough to see in the
world
that i now at this point in my life
realize there are tons of things that i
need to see
here in this country and a road trip
could potentially be the best way
to see them i think to do it effectively
you need
an amount of time where you can be as
leisurely as possible
there's no deadline and there's no i've
got to make it from chicago to st
louis by sundown to get to this place at
this time
i think you really need to be able to
take your time and
uh and kind of like let the road take
you
where you need to go it feels like you
need a mission though ultimately
like there's a reason you need to be in
san francisco that's like the kerouac
thing
you have to meet somebody somewhere kind
of loosely in a few weeks
and then it's the as you struggle on
towards that mission
you meet weird characters that get in
your way but ultimately sort of
create an experience i think having a
loose deadline is good
but that's a beginning and an end point
and what i mean is i don't want to have
to be
all right we're leaving say boston on
sunday night
let's get to new york by monday morning
and then from new york we're going to go
to philly and we've got to be in philly
at 4. a
vague beginning and end is fine but i
think having very strict
guidelines in between will rob you of
certain experiences along the way
if you have a time frame to get from
philly to indianapolis
and some awesome [ __ ] starts to happen
in philly do you really want to have to
cut it short because you got to be in
indianapolis by
sunup why do you have to be anywhere by
any time
for any reason really plans change plans
change
all the time exactly but if we're
talking about um having a mission
or the type of road trip i just think it
would be best to have it
as loose and uh flexible as possible
i don't know you gotta make hard
deadlines
and then break them totally change the
plans disappoint people
break promises that's the way of life
somebody's waiting for you in st
louis and all of a sudden you you fell
in love with a biker
in new york i don't know i don't know
what you're up to i can appreciate that
um but on a trip like that i feel like
a trip with deadlines is for a different
point in your life
and at this point in my life i don't
want any of the deadlines because it's
not about
meeting someone and disappointing them
in st louis it's about
me not disappointing myself you want to
have you want to have enough time
in what you're doing to make sure that
you get the full breadth of every
experience that you encounter
how would you fully experience a place
how would you
you know i i don't think i've actually
fully experienced boston like how if you
were showing up to
to a city for a week on this road trip
what would you do
so i'm gonna answer that in two parts a
few years ago i had an opportunity to
move out of boston
and the thing that kept me here no
question about it was the fact that i
felt like i had a
um a contract with my students
and i did not i felt like a great many
of them took a leap of faith
uh by joining my gym and like you know
asking me to teach them what i know
and when i had an opportunity to leave
boston i thought of those people
and i thought i want to fulfill my
obligation to them so because
i made a decision to stay here i then
that summer made a decision to endear
myself to the city of boston and i tried
to find lots and lots of different
things to do
i can tell you that the coolest thing
that i found to do in this city
is um the mfa
where they have like on friday nights
they'll have like different exhibits and
stuff
and they'll have like little beer carts
and food tents and you can go
do a painting class off in the on the
side
very cool night of things to do but in
general
whenever i'm in a new city i try not to
pay attention to google and i try not to
do anything
that i find on a travel site the best
thing to do
is to walk out of your hotel or wherever
it is you're staying and find the most
normal looking bar have a drink and talk
to a bartender so
people the people the people and then
you can experience that town the way
that they
experience it even in a city where there
are tons of tourist attractions
locals probably visit the same tourist
attractions when they have visitors come
from out of town
but you want to see how they view those
places and how they visit them
and you want to go to eat where they're
going to eat like
you know you're going to for the most
part
the north end is not a place where i
would take someone and say
hey this is boston's the pinnacle of
boston dining
because it's very touristy there are a
handful of really good restaurants there
but i want to know where the where the
i want to go to bogey's place i want to
know like the the down low spots where
the hell is bogey's place it's like a
little steakhouse in the back of jm
curly's exactly
like a shitty bar yeah it's just a bar
with like bar food
but i think they're like um boston
it is in boston yeah it's like south
boston no it's in
um it's in the downtown area
like um i don't know what the
neighborhoods are called here honestly
because they call
they have an area called downtown boston
and i don't even know what the hell that
means
i think he's near the financial district
where's southie because i've heard about
the southie
southeast south boston but is there is
there difference between south boston
and southie
no it's the same thing no but like you
know the mythical south
i think the mythical southie is uh
something that's
long gone now and the term now
actually is sobo oh no
yeah it's it's changed what who who took
over what
what's the you know the goodwill hunting
personality that's southie isn't it
strong accent those badass dudes i came
here right at the end
of like what was south boston so when i
got
and my gym is in south boston the
neighborhood was just starting to change
so i think
as gentrification happened and they
started building more luxury
condominiums
they were buying all these old
businesses out all the mom and pop
businesses and i think
that kind of changed the the makeup of
the community and it wasn't only because
there was an
influx of new young people with
disposable income
it's because there's an exodus of the
the older people who kind of grew up and
raised their families there because
they were being offered humongous sums
of money for their homes that they had
bought like in the late 70s and early
80s
so that they could develop those areas
so you have a combination of the influx
of new people
in the exodus of the old and now you
just got this totally new neighborhood
in its place what do you love about
boston
is there a love still for boston
you certainly have the love of the thing
that's gone as well
yeah i think i don't want to pinpoint
pin this on boston because it's
happening in all great cities
as these areas become gentrified what's
happening is the personality and the
character of the neighborhood is just
being run out
and i have nothing against people coming
in and making money and things like that
but
when you do it at the expense of the
culture the character and the
personality of the neighborhood
i mean you're kind of standing on the
shoulders of giants these are the people
that came here and built these areas up
uh it happens here in in boston it
happens in all over new york
uh happens on the west coast so
what i love about boston is not nearly
as romantic as what it might have been
15 years ago and what i used to love
about new york
what i love about boston is that um
it's walkable um the food scene
is on is on the rise here um
but i think you're you're hard-pressed
to find the charm
that people think of when they think of
old boston and old new england city
see i see it differently people
sometimes criticize like mit
like for the thing that it is now but i
think it is
always like that i
tend to prefer to carry the flame
of the his of the greatness the greatest
moments of his history
and like sort of enjoy that the echoes
of that in the halls of mit in the same
way in boston you think about the
history
and that history lives on in the few
individuals
like you can't just look around where
boston is now and be like what has
boston become
i think it was always carried by a
minority of individuals
i i think we kind of look back in
history and think like
times were greater in a certain kind of
dimension back then but
that's because we remember uh this is a
ridiculous
non-data-driven assertion of mine is we
remember just the
the the brightest stars of that history
and so we romanticize it but i think if
you look around now
those special people are still living in
boston for which boston will be
remembered as a great city
in like 50 years i think you're probably
right but isn't there some sort of
theory about
the point that there's like a certain
age in your life where things resonate
differently to you like i think they've
done studies where
most people stop searching for new music
after age 19.
most dads you see like wearing super old
clothes like the
that's the style of the time period of
the last great part of their life
so like there's an evolution in in
people and it could also be the memories
of where they live
and when i was 17 of course my
neighborhood was the best then because i
was having the most fun
and we always kind of look at things
through uh that that tint i think
and you're right and i don't think
there's anything wrong with the way
cities are evolving now it's just not um
i i i prefer the time of like a mom and
pop store
not a fabricated like uh gastropub that
could just be
like on a four-lane super highway on
your on your way out of epcot center
and it's actually owned by like some
conglomerate but there's still the
special places like i
this takes us back to the road trip is
um
maybe i tend to romanticize the
experiences of like the diners in the
middle of nowhere
what would you say makes for like
it feels like life is made up of these
experiences
that are that maybe on paper seem
mundane
but are actually somehow give you a
chance
to pause and reflect on life with like
a certain kind of people whether like
really close friends or complete
strangers maybe alcohol is involved in
the middle of nowhere it seems like road
trip
facilitates that if you allow it to like
what do you think makes for those kind
of experience have you had any
i think in the context of a road trip i
think it's like hyper localization
and i think it is um those
those experiences along the way
with people and the people that you're
with will color the experiences
differently depending
on the person the road trip you took was
uh with somebody else or along so
i've driven up and down the east coast
several times when i
drove from la to new york my friend was
on the run from the cops yeah so
we were trying to get traffic tickets
yeah
yeah we were trying to get out of la
because um
he was going to have to go away for a
little while yeah so we drove from
la and we just you know we're young kids
we had no idea what we were doing
and we drove east and then you know we
had an unbelievable trip
mostly because we didn't really have a
destination we didn't really have a time
frame
thank goodness uh because he got
arrested again in pennsylvania
so we got kind of stuck there and then
um you know and then we we drove back to
la when he got
out in pennsylvania um
but all the stops along the way were
kind of like
weird things like you have no money
right so you're finding that like
a little diamond in the rough place to
eat the diner you talk about like that
place
i i once was in where was i i think i
was in buenos aires and the guy that i
was with
he said i know this quaint little spot
around the corner
and i was young i was like 25 and i
thought the coolest thing in the world
would be
to be such a citizen of the world that
you know these quaint little spots
around the corner in like all these
great cities like
i know where to get this great chicken
sandwich in argentina i know where to
get this great meal in costa rica
i know where to get this super local
like um egg in another country
i always thought that that was really
cool the ability to do that
anywhere in the world you get closer
with that guy
went out through the trip i found that
like so i took i took a trip across the
united states with a
with a guy friend of mine we had
different goals i was searching for a
meeting in life and he was searching for
um
what's the politically correct way of
phrasing it but just
uh basically trying to sleep with every
kind of woman that this world
has to offer what's the difference
between those two things well i guess
the different kinds of meanings i i mean
i just
i i still think that you can't find
meaning
between a woman's legs i suppose uh that
maybe they tried all of them
but there was a tension there we grew
closer with those experiences
but we've gotten in fights you know
there was a lot of like
literal almost fights and then we were
close and there was like
silences but then we were like brothers
and this whole weird
journey of friendship that we went on i
think anytime you
spend that much time in uh like a small
space with another person
you're gonna have the the different
parts of the relationship will manifest
themselves you'll have the periods of
closeness
you'll have the periods of vulnerability
where it's like maybe you're driving
through denver and it's three in the
morning and you talk about something you
might not have otherwise talked about
you'll have the periods where you don't
want to see that [ __ ] ever again
right he didn't and depending could be
because of anything
yeah um but the guy that i drove twice
with
we are still we're still in contact
we're still buddies
we we have very different goals also
um but at that point in our lives we
were not we never even contemplated the
meaning of life
we were about probably more to the point
of the friend that you drove with
we were more about racking up
experiences whatever they were right
i want to be able to retell this hmm
stories
yeah i want to be able to retell this
and it's got to sound cool
like i don't want to retell a story
about yeah and then we drove through
alabama and they've got a lovely library
and i checked out this book and you know
i'm not interested in retelling that
do you remember any um well this is a
kids show
do you remember any stories that the
kids would enjoy from those
times they were profound in some kind of
way
there were some impactful moments
on the beginning of our road trip where
we had no money and as a couple of kids
who knew nothing
we literally had to we stopped in vegas
and we went to circus circus
at the time they had three dollar
blackjack and we had like 12 bucks and
my buddy was a kind of a degenerate
gambler so he knew what was up i was
just like kind of stuffing chips in my
pockets making sure we could pay for the
gas
um and just being at a point which is
like a starting line and
like we drove from la to vegas which is
only about four hours
and being at the starting line and
realizing like we may not even like
get off the starting line here and if we
don't what are we doing we're going to
be two guys stuck in vegas with no money
we can't go west because you're going to
get pinched
we have no money to go east what the
hell are we going to do we're going to
wind up in vegas
so you know that that was kind of a
profound thing where you just
it's a turning it potentially could have
been a turning point in our lives
had we not made enough money to to
continue going east
that's the beautiful thing about road
trips when you're broke it's like
in retrospect everything turned out fine
but
you're facing the complete darkness the
uncertainty of the possibilities laid
before you
and like i don't know if you were
confident at that time but like
i was really full of self-doubt like
just like all i could see is all the
trajectories where you just screw up
your life like what am i doing with my
life i'm
a failure like all these dreams i've had
i've never realized i'm a complete piece
of [ __ ] all those kinds of i had no
concept of consequence i i like i was
i probably had toxoplasmosis i had
literally no concept of consequence
immediate gratification was all i cared
about
oh so existentialist yeah it did not it
did not
even enter my mind at in my like early
20s
that anything that i was doing at that
point could reverberate for the rest of
my life
i think part of me didn't even think i'd
make it this far and so
i was not interested in like the long
play i remember thinking like why should
i be acting now
in a way that might impact a point in my
life i never reach
and yet now you are a man
who searches for meaning in life at
least
i would say to put another way you have
um
you think deeply about this world and
in a philosophical context while also
appreciating
the violence of hurting other
uh friends of yours right on a regular
basis so what
why do you think i mean maybe there's a
broader question there but
also a personal question it seems that
people who fight for prolonged
periods of time like jiu jitsu people
mixed martial arts people
even military folks become overtime
philosophers
what what is that is that is there a
parallel between
fighting and violence and the
philosophical depth with which you now
have a
from the starting point of being the
full existentialist of like
just living in the moment to like being
uh introspective
uh human now i would say to that
being a a soldier or a warrior
uh hundreds of years ago is probably
what started the marriage between
martial arts and
philosophy if you're constantly under
someone else's charge and you're told to
go out and walk in a line
and you know overtake some germanic
tribe somewhere
and that happens all the time um
your job is being a soldier there's on
any given day you might not come home
so i think that you have to start your
day by thinking deeply about
how you've lived to that point and the
people that are living in and around you
and how you've treated them and i think
that probably is what started the
marriage of
being kind of like a philosophical
martial artist you've got to really like
on a daily basis take stock of of what's
going on around you
and inside you because we all suffer
with this kind of
uh idea if today's my last day
did i do it right and we don't really do
it so much nowadays because we're so
comfortable
but if we're being marched out to war
every day i think you'd see people live
a little bit differently
uh you know and you that you treat the
people around you a little bit
differently
do you think there's echoes of that in
just even the sport
of uh like grappling and jiu jitsu where
you're facing your own mortality we
don't really think of it that way but
to be honest i think that a lot of
people that train in a martial art
in contemporary society i don't consider
them all martial artists
i think just because you train a martial
art does not mean you're a martial
artist there are so many people that
use martial arts as a form of exercise
and like this little piece of
um self-concept they use
martial arts as a tagline in their
instagram bio
and it's really a form of exercise it's
something they do it's not something
they are
and i think there's a big difference
there there's a bunch of stuff mixed up
in there because the instagram thing
is something you do for
it's also it could be something you are
for display versus who
you are in the private moments of
searching and thinking and struggling
and all that kind of stuff instagram is
a surface layer
that much of modern society uh
operates in which is really problematic
because there's that gap
between the person you show to the world
and the person you are in private life
and if you make
majority of your project of the human
project of your sort of
few years on this earth the optimization
of the
public instagram profile then you never
develop this
private person but it does seem that if
you do jujitsu long enough it's very
difficult not to fall into like
this has become a personal journey an
intellectual journey
because like if you get your ass kicked
thousands of times there's a certain
point
to where that maybe it's like a defense
mechanism but that turns
into some kind of deeply profound
introspective experience versus like
exercise yeah
so let me let me go back first and
address the instagram point which
i think there's a difference between
people who
whose instagram is intrinsically tied to
their profession
and they have to put a specific profile
out there and i think in general
people who truthfully are their
businesses tied to their instagram
profile
i want to exclude them i think that most
people
instagram is how they want to be seen
and
it's not always congruent with who you
are but i think
there is a level of dishonesty there
yeah
like this is how i want people to see me
i'm gonna put all this stuff in my
instagram bio but
that's really not me and when you do
that
um i think it's it's a little
disingenuous and you're right there's
not
you're never really going to marry those
two things together and it gets tough
let me uh sorry to interrupt let me push
back on something that's a good time to
address
uh the the many flaws of the great and
powerful john clark okay uh
le le let's let's go there because it's
interesting
you strive so hard for excellence
in your life and for extreme confidence
that you are visibly and physically off
put by people who are
who have not achieved competence
do you think we should be nicer
to the people who are those early like
you mentioned
a person who first picks up an art picks
up is
becomes vegan starts throwing crossfit
start doing jiu jitsu for the first time
and create that as their you know
they're they're struggling through this
like
who am i and they're really overly proud
and it's kind of ridiculous
and you and your wise chair i've seen
seen many battles
yeah that you see the ridiculousness of
that
i tend to i'm learning
to give those folks not to mock them
and and to sort of give them a chance to
do their ridiculousness
because i think i was that too let me
first clarify
i want to be clear about what you mean
when you say a level of competence
now i i've never won a world
championship i've never
you know there are plenty of things in
my life where i've not
achieved what um
most people would consider to be the
penultimate
level of success now that's
accomplishments
it's accomplishments it's ribbons it's
things like that and it's not that those
things don't mean anything to me and the
fact that i haven't in some
arenas is uh is something that
i want to change which is we can talk
about that in a second but
i think that there's a difference
between the very eager
noob of whatever it is they're doing
who does the thing so that they can
signal they do the thing that's the
person i have less respect for
so we know each other primarily through
jiu jitsu look at a jiu jitsu tournament
there's this there's this idea that
people espouse online
i respect anyone with the guts to get on
the mat and put it on the line and sign
up for a tournament
that is the biggest load of [ __ ]
i have ever heard this is great do you
know do you know how easy it is
for you to put your name on something
and pay the registration fee and walk in
there
that's not the hard part that's the
easiest part
i don't care if you lose your first
match but i respect the person
who signs up for the tournament
registers for the tournament
goes on a diet loses weight the right
way trains their ass off
and does the things properly and then
goes on the mat
the person who simply signs their name
on the registration form
and jumps on the mat if they haven't
done these other things they actually
have nothing to lose
because what they've done is they've
stepped onto the mat in the ring in the
cage
with a bucket full of excuses yeah sure
you signed up
but when you but you you're not really
vulnerable because
you didn't run you didn't do this you
didn't do all the things you're supposed
to do
the person who eliminates every possible
excuse
and then steps on the mat and gets their
ass kicked in the first round
i have so much more respect for that
person than the person who does nothing
and maybe unnatural ability wins a
couple of matches
and then you know writes on facebook on
how i lost to the eventual champion
that's worth zero that's worth zero and
in that process
what did you learn about yourself you
learned about yourself
that you've got a natural level of
aptitude for whatever this activity is
that you're doing
but you didn't actually learn how to
maximize it through
training and through dedication and
through all these other things uh
i'm i'm an incredibly interested
novice musician i love i like to play
bass but i don't put that on anything
and you know i stink at it i would
really love to be sick at it
i'm currently not but like i'm not
running around
you know talking about entering you know
any of those other things like i i do it
it's for myself and i want to i want to
reach a level of competence in that
so the person that you have respect for
the person who takes it fully
seriously takes takes the effort fully
seriously so for base that would be
that you agree with yourself that you're
going to perform live and just in your
own private moments your private
thoughts
you're not going to give yourself an
excuse out like i'm just going to have
fun it's just a nice experience you're
going to
you're going to think i'm going to try
to be the best possible bass player
given
given everything that's going on in my
life but i'm going to do my
like actually and put it all on the line
and if i
fail that it that's not because i didn't
try
it's because i'm a failure exactly
and then and then sit in that sick
feeling of like
i'm a failure but isn't that an
important thing to know absolutely
but there there's a there's a
that's like the best thing it could be
but sometimes it's fun to lose
yourself in the in the in the bragging
in the
yeah in the lesser ways of life and i
think
i'm careful not to uh because too many
people in my life
when i brought them with like a little
candle of a fire of a dream
they would just go like you know they
would just blow that
fire out uh that they would dismiss me
because they see
like you know i would say i said i've
said a lot of ridiculous stuff but the
one
you know i've always dreamed about uh
like putting
like i always dreamed of having
this world full of robots and you know
every time i would
uh bring these ideas up they'll be shut
down by the different people by my
parents but
you know uh you know then you need to
first
get to get an education you need to
succeed in these dimensions
in notice you do all these things you
have to get good grades you have to
like there's all this stuff that it's
indirect
or direct ways of blowing out that
little ridiculous dream
that you present and it's like
you know i remember sort of bringing up
i don't know um things like
becoming a state champion and wrestling
right
it's a it's a weird dance because of
course the coaches will tell
they'll kind of dismiss that it's like
okay
okay uh but at the same time it feels
like in those early days
you have to preserve that little little
fire that's like
johnny i don't know if you know who that
is as a designer at apple he was a chief
designer he's behind
most iphone all that stuff and he he
always talked about that he wouldn't
bring
his ideas to steve jobs until they were
matured because he would always [ __ ] on
them
uh he would he wanted them to like
little as little babies like live for a
little bit
before they get completely shut down and
i always think about that when i see a
beginner sort of bragging on instagram
you have to be careful let them play
with that little dream
you know are you playing with a little
dream that you're nurturing and you're
trying to take that little flame and
you're trying to create
a a roaring blaze with it or are you
playing with the idea of it
and behind behind that there's no
substance
it's hard to know the difference that's
what i struggle with is it i don't think
it necessarily is certainly you're wrong
and when i say instagram i don't want to
impugn a bunch of strangers but i have a
gym with a lot of members
and and i can tell you that the number
of years i've been in the gym
when someone comes to me and says this
is my goal i don't i don't tell them yes
or no
in general but i know i can tell by the
way they say it to me
i can thin slice it i've seen the look
on people's faces
and when people start to like say they
want to do x y and z
i know right off the bat this person is
either going to put an effort in or
they're not going to put an effort in
so to me it's about the effort behind
that
if you're busting your ass and you're a
newt at something and you're brand new
but you're working really hard and you
have a series of like moderate
successes in that like that's the guy i
want to champion
because that persistence and that grit
over time those successes will
no longer be moderate they'll be huge
but the person who's having moderate
success by doing nothing
chances are they'll never learn to put
that work in and the successes will
never grow
you have an admiration for mike tyson i
love him
i'm just gonna let that sit for a brief
moment um
why i think there's a combination of
factors one is like
the timeliness of his career and like
the age i was
when he like came to prominence um
the raw brutal violence
and the raw brutal honesty when he
speaks
i think it's easy for people to hear him
or see his life
and cast him aside as some simeonesque
uh
like just [ __ ] scourge on society but
when you hear him speak like this is not
a guy who's unintelligent
this is a guy who knows himself better
than probably most of us know
ourselves it's disarming and uh
you know that's a humongous part of my
admiration for him who is mike tyson
because you there's it feels like
there's similarities between him and you
there's a it feels like there's a
violent person
in there but also really kind person and
they're all like living together in a
little house and you're the same there's
a thoughtful person
but there's also a scary violent person
and they're like having a picnic
they're having a picnic i think there
are dialectical tensions in everyone
these like
opposing forces yeah that are constantly
pulling at you
and at different points in your life
like it's sliding scale
and i think that uh certainly when i was
a younger person
there was a lot more manifestation of
the violence and a lot less of the
kindness
um people who were not as close to me
probably saw more of the violent side
only the very close people to me saw
like
what would pass for the kind side and
now that's sliding in the other
direction
uh and i i worry actually sometimes that
there could be a situation where i need
that old version of me
and he's getting further and further
away and i can't call him up if i need
him
and that that concerns me to it to a
certain degree
the sad aging warrior seeing his greater
self paid away
like but you still compete is that that
person return it seems like for mike
tyson that person returned
at the prospect of competition it
returns
but i've learned i've learned better how
to
manifest it in competition in terms of
like the effects that that type of
emotion has on you physically in the
middle of a competition
so i've better learn how to utilize that
energy
but i think another side effect of this
is like having a gym where you're
a bigger guy and you're the head
instructor you can't be as mean and
violent as you once were
because you're also now trying to run a
business and
you spend so long so many so many years
trying not to be mean and
to you know soften your your technique a
little bit
that that all of a sudden just becomes
who you are and and i don't necessarily
like that so i've been trying to reclaim
that a little bit
uh on the mat but
i think in competition
there's there has to be
an athlete really wants to score the
points
a fighter really wants to incapacitate
you and put you in a position where they
can
do their own bidding and the result in a
jiu jitsu match might just still be two
points
but the motivations are very very
different what do you make of
tyson and joe rogan saying that he was
aroused by violence do you think that's
insane do you think that's deeply honest
for him and do you think that rings true
for
many of us others who practices in
different degrees
i don't i can't speak for a lot of
people and i think that
it's was a brutally honest statement by
him and i think it's something that
even if a lot of people feel it they're
not that comfortable admitting it or
saying it
yeah but i think like there's
there is great joy in
like landing a flush right hand on
someone's jaw
and then watching them crumble you don't
even feel it you ever play baseball as a
kid
you can hit a bass hit off the end of
the bat and it will sting your hands
because of the way that you hit it you
can hit a home run
and you won't feel anything and it'll
just feel so good in your hands and
that's i think that like
one of the the joys of uh physical
contact when you do it the right way
and that goes for all physical contact
when you do it the right way
the physical pleasure you can derive
from it and the mental
pleasure it's uh it's unparalleled
but that's different let me draw a
distinction i'm not
i've had the fortune of being a wrestler
and i would draw a distinction between a
very well executed and competition
double leg single leg takedown or a pin
there's some as an ocd person there's
something so
comforting about a well-executed pin
because it's like
two seconds and it's just like
everything is flush and nice and it
like it's all clean and i mean okay this
ocd person who likes to align
so it's just beautiful okay that's good
technique
wrestling also provides you
maybe more than other sports the feeling
of
dominating another human yes of breaking
no
not just of them being very cocky
and very powerful you feel this power of
another human being
and then you breaking them and like
i'm not as honest as mike tyson but
that's
that uh uh i don't think
i've ever sort of looked in the mirror
and said
like that that was in i enjoyed that
aspect of it
but it certainly seems like you chased
that
so when i was a wrestler in high school
um
i lost so many matches because of over
aggressiveness um like you know i would
pick the top position and let you stand
just so that i could do a matt return
and i wasn't trying to return you to the
mat i was actually trying to like drive
you
through the mat and through the ground
like i took like i
it gave me joy to do that yeah like it
wasn't like i was trying to
you know just return you to the mat so
that it could pin you
that what you just talked about like the
the dominating another person i used to
look at that as
you've got someone who in theory is
equally trained and equally skilled as
you
are and you're you're absolutely out
there totally dominating them
there's joy in that you could get in an
mma fight and you could
take someone down and you can mount them
and
all that feels great but when you start
raining down the punches on their face
from mount and like dropping elbows and
stuff like there's another level of
satisfaction there
and it's it's tough to describe and i
don't think that it's
everyone uh is made for it when
i was a i think when i was a senior in
high school my wrestling coach said look
you've got to stop with all this crazy
aggressive
wrestling like they try to turn me into
a technician
and and it and it did work to a degree
and it was a humongous shift for me
in terms of success but it wasn't the
same level of
enjoyment out of it um like
i mean i got disqualified from new
england because my coach said crossface
and i cross-faced and he said harder
and i basically wound up and blasted a
kid in the face and his nose got you
know busted everywhere
but i didn't think not to do it because
that felt good
it felt good to cross-face him like that
i was that was a lot of like
that's a weird american warrior ethos
that i've
picked up but i also have them either
the russian the setia brothers that
don't see it
don't see it as that they they don't get
draw
they think that there is a tension
between the art
of the martial art and the violence of
the martial arts
i agree it's a poetic way i could put it
but they're not so
fascinated with this dan gable
dominating another human
they think of the effortless the
effortlessness
of the technique and your mastery of the
art is exhibited in its effortlessness
how much you lose yourself in the moment
and the timing that just the beauty of a
timing
like there's much more like one example
in judo but also in wrestling
you can look at the foot sweep wrestlers
in america and even judo players in
america
much of the world don't admire the
beauty of the foot sweep
but a well-timed foot sweep which is a
way to sort of off balance to find the
right timing to just
effortlessly uh change the tape
turn the tables of uh dominate your
opponent
is is seen as the highest form of
mastery in
in russian wrestling and in case of
judos and in japanese judo
it's interesting i'm not sure i'm not
sure what what that tension is about
i think it actually takes me back to i
don't know if you listen to uh dan carl
in hardcore history
and genghis khan if you've ever i've
read a great
great book on jenga's god yeah i'm so
i'm still trying to adjust
most of my life said genghis khan but
the right pronunciation is uh
actually changus khan
there's a tension there we kind of think
i don't know we i kind of thought as
genghis khan as a ultra violent
a leader of ultra violent men but
another view another way to see them is
the
people who warriors that
valued extreme competence and mastery of
the
art of uh fighting with weapons with
bows with the
horse riding all that kind of stuff and
i'm not sure exactly
where to place them on my sort of
thinking about
violence in in our human history
i think in the context of like combat
sports
i think there's a difference between an
athlete winning a contest
under a certain set of rules and a
fighter winning a fight
under those exact same rules there's a
different approach to it
and i don't think one is any better than
the other um
like in mma i think a great example
would be
george st pierre george st pierre is a
tremendous
it's a tremendous athlete and he
considers himself to be a martial artist
first
he's trying to win an athletic
competition like
nick diaz is trying to bust your ass
yeah right there's a different
approach to it and yes they've had
different results at the highest level
of competition
but it's difficult to attribute the
difference in results
just to their approach to the sport
because they're different human beings
with different abilities and different
different
uh physical attributes um
the saito brothers have that luxury of
being able to
talk about the beauty of a perfectly
timed slide by
right there are other wrestlers that
will never be able to pull that off
and therefore they have to pursue other
ways to defeat someone and maybe it is
the dan gable
breaking a man's spirit by outworking
him type thing which
is beautiful in its own way uh but
we we we tend to self-select the ways in
which we're able to be successful
and then kind of take a deep dive into
that what do you think is more beautiful
brute force or
effortless execution
of uh technique that dominates another
human
i think it's a subjective thing based on
what skills you perceive yourself to
have
i'm never i've never been a slick uh
super
athletic dexterous competitor in
anything
and i've always been more of an i've got
to outwork you i've got to outgrind you
i gotta help mean you
and so because i've lived that i tend to
see the beauty in that more because i
have a perceptual awareness
that i don't have for the people who
have the luxury of being very slick and
athletic and
and using beautiful technique now that
said there's a phenomenal
little video the other day i sent to a
friend
of a compilation of foot sweeps by leota
machida
in mma and they're so beautiful and
they're so awesome
and it's not that i don't have an
appreciation for those
but i can't emulate those because i lack
the physical
ability to do that whereas i
i at least have a chance to emulate some
of the people who
do it through grit and throughout
working people
but i would love to return to genghis
khan
and get your thoughts about like i have
so many mixed feelings
about whether he
is evil or not whether
the violence that he brought to the
world had
ultimately the fact that he had maybe
kind of uh like dan carlin describes
cleansed
the landscape it's like a reset for the
world through violence
had ultimately
a progressive effect on human
civilization
even though in the short term it led to
massive you could say suffering
i don't know what to make of that man
what uh what are your thoughts on
jenkins gone
um i think it's always difficult to look
at a historical figure
and their actions of their time through
a modern day lens
because it's very it's easy for us to um
kind of you know impugn their
achievements and the things that they
did
and say oh well you know what he did was
wrong
well of course that can be true but a
lot of times
we don't actually have any real good
context or concept of
the the times they were living in and
what really was deemed wrong and what
really wasn't we're looking at it
through a very cushy modern lens
that being said from what i've read
about genghis khan
uh yeah he was a violent dude but also
he gave you an option
he when he when he got to a village he
said look
i'm gonna we're gonna you have a choice
you can come with us
or you can run and you know he gave them
an option to join
uh his legion of fighters who he took
very good care of you know he was the
the first military leader uh to pay
his soldiers families when they died
and he did that based on the the booty
that they got when they
raided a village he took that money he
took his share and they divided that up
amongst the soldiers and then the
soldiers families
i think he also is credited with uh
first like horseback male roots or
something like that right isn't he the
godfather of the modern postal system
or something something like that yeah
he's the bernie sanders of the uh
uh the mongol empire i do think the
the offering of surrender is an
interesting one because um
it's interesting like as a thought
experiment whether you would sacrifice
your way of
like the pride of nations or the
nationalism pride of your country
whether you're willing to give that up
uh for uh you know to survive
it depends on who depends on you if you
have a
if you have a family and like young kids
and stuff like that i think your
your obligation is primarily to them and
therefore
surrender has to be something that you
consider in that in that moment in time
so that you can uh take care of those
people if you're a man alone and you've
got like all these principles and all
this other stuff and you just don't
you're not down with what genghis khan
is doing and what he's selling
yeah try and escape do your thing and
just know that you know what wait's on
the other side of that for you
potentially
but i think if there's someone else out
there that depends on you
your obligation should be to them it
feels like
historically people valued principles
more than life
in this weight of like what do i value
more the principles i hold versus
survival
it seems that now we don't value
principles as much
your principles could be also religion
it could be your values whatever
we're okay sort of sacrificing those for
to preserve our survival and that
applies in all forms like
actual survival or like on
social media like preserving your
reputation all those kinds of things
it seems like we
especially in america value individual
life that death is somehow a really bad
thing
as opposed to saying sacrificing your
principles is a very bad thing and
everybody dies
and it's okay to die as what's horrible
is to sacrifice your principles of who
you are
just to live another day i think a big
problem is people don't really even know
what their principles are anymore
people you know um social media
and just the way that we live nowadays
where we're separated from the human
contact like this like we're not
you're not contacting people in a
community anymore you're not
whether you're religious or not like
you're not you're not congregating at a
church
you're not part of a parish like you
would be like in you know down south
you're not part of that community
anymore and so
it's difficult to figure out what your
principles and values are because you're
constantly jumping from one bucket to
the next
uh online and you don't get a lot of
like
direct like reasonable feedback from
people
you just get [ __ ] feedback like oh
you don't believe this well you're a
jerk
i think the hard thing currently is
having the integrity and character to
stick by principles one under
i don't want to equate murder of in the
genghis khan times
to uh social media cancer culture
but it certainly doesn't feel good when
people are attacking on social media
and it does take a lot of integrity to
uh
without anger without emotion without
without being without mocking others or
attacking others unfairly
standing by the ideas you hold
or in another way
standing by your friends standing by
this
little group like loyalty of
the people that you know are good people
i find that uh in in cancer culture one
of the sad things
is whenever somebody gets quote unquote
cancelled
everybody just gets all their friends
become really quiet
and don't defend them or worse
i mean quiet is at least understandable
they kind of
signal that they throw them under the
bus i guess
uh is one way to put it and that that's
something i think about
a lot because from coming for me it's
like
i i hold an ethic i don't know if others
hold this ethic maybe it's
this like russian mobster ethic of like
you should help your friends bury the
body
you shouldn't criticize your friends for
committing the murder
like there are certain levels of like
you know
yeah you have that discussion after you
bury the body
that like maybe you shouldn't have done
that murder thing right
uh i don't know you know i understand
that that's a problematic
um what's the terminology
that's a problematic ethical framework
within which to operate but
at the same time it feels like what else
do we have in this world except
the brotherhood the sisterhood the love
we have for a very small community
but perhaps that's the wrong way of
thinking perhaps the 21st century would
be
defined uh by the dissipation of this
community of this loyalty concept
no we're all just individuals i think
you're right and i think you have to
have some sort of core
framework of principles and beliefs that
you operate on
and i think when i was what i was
referencing is a little bit
different and but to speak to your point
you you need a framework
um of core principles
on which you can then base a lot of your
other decisions like i believe
these three things to be true whatever
they are and that will help inform other
decisions you make in your life
as far as how you treat your friends
i've got i've got probably three friends
that
if they called me right now and said
let's bury the body sorry lex i gotta go
there are other people in my life that
if they said uh hey we've got to go bury
the body
i would say who is this
you know yeah so i think it it depends
on the relationship
i want that's a good it's a really good
measure i would love to have
i would love that to be in your profile
people put like pronouns
i would love to put like uh honestly
like objectively not self-report but
objective
how many people in your life if they
committed murder you would not ask any
questions and you would help them
hide the body right like i would love to
know that number for people yeah
and and i think it's a weird thing too
because you think right away like okay
it must be the group of people that are
the closest to you that's who you're
first thinking of right
but obviously for like my best friend i
would do it no question about it
but i've got other people that are close
to me that
are close to me in other ways and i
probably wouldn't do that only because i
don't think they do it for me
yeah and and that is a consideration um
so i guess is the principle there then
that
you do for your friends what you think
they would do for you is that the
underlying principle
or do you just have a blind loyalty to
you know
people in your life for different
reasons i got people that are not on my
inner circle
that i probably wouldn't help change a
tire at two in the morning if they were
on the highway but if they called me and
said hey we got to bury the body
i might show up for that it's just these
weird different connections yeah
it's fascinating yeah i have uh close
friends that like
i probably exactly the tire is a good
example would be like can't you find
somebody else to do this
i think part of that is just this leap
of faith into like giving yourself
to the other person that
uh creates a deep connection that makes
life
fulfilling like meaningful
that doesn't exist if you don't take
that leap i mean it's not about the
murder we're sort of focusing
i think that's a i think you have to uh
what does it cross that bridge when you
get there i'm not exactly sure this is
just a thought experiment
but it's it's i think about that a lot
especially these covet times
and as like people become more and more
isolated and separated from each other
like how important is it to have those
deep deep connections to other humans
i think especially like what you're
talking about there have you ever seen
the movie the town
there's a great line in the movie where
one of the main characters walks into
his friend's house
and he says i need your help
we're going to go hurt some people and
you can never ask me about it again
and the friend looks up and he says
whose car we taking
that that is the type of person you need
in your life and the people
like there are people that will walk
through that door and say that to you
and you drop everything you're doing
and then there's the people that walk
through your door and you're like you
know what i got a hot pocket in the
microwave
i'm a little bit i'm a little bit tied
up right now but i'd love to help you
out but
you know i don't want to do that and you
don't have that that deep connection
with those people
you mentioned uh some principles that
you've uh
changed your mind on is there do you
want to go there
is there some interesting principles and
the process of changing that uh
is useful to talk about i can't really
cite a specific thing
except that understanding that
the principles that you have at
different points in your life can change
and it's okay to change them without
being a total [ __ ] and being bullied by
other people
into thinking what you thought was wrong
if you come to these conclusions
of your own volition and you decide to
change them that's great and it can be
really it can be really liberating it's
really liberating to have an idea that
you hold
so true to your your core
belief system and then to actually have
someone change your mind for you and be
okay with it
as opposed to being like no i gotta die
with this
i gotta die with this it's really
liberating there are definitely our
ideas you wanna die on that hill and
no one's ever gonna change your mind but
it's really
liberating to be confident enough to say
change my mind i'm lucky enough to have
some smart [ __ ] around me
who can tell me listen you're being a
total [ __ ]
like let's let's rethink this or like i
have one friend who does the five
wise all the time and he loves backing
me into a corner and
what's the five wise you just like when
someone makes a statement about
something
to really get to the core issue they say
if you ask
why five times make a statement well why
is that
and you answer that well why and you
phrase the y's differently obviously but
then you get to the core they say five
times you can get to the core of the
issue
and uh that's a challenging thing but i
find later in life
it's so liberating for me to be
confident enough to be like
man was i [ __ ] way off the mark on
this
and have my mind changed and be able to
say that to others that i was wrong
totally that ability and i never used to
have that
and it's it feels real good
and there's a hunger for that too um
yeah if you're you're so right actually
on a personal level it feels very good
exactly as you said it's liberating
because you're free to then think
as opposed to defend yeah
without thinking yeah you get so sick of
defending the same thing
over and over and over and you start to
think about it
and it's like well i i would really like
to evolve my thought process here and
when you're constantly defending
you know one point it's difficult to let
other ideas in
you you you discount the possibility
that you can have your mind change when
you're constantly on the defense like
you have to have a crack in
in the front line in order to let a new
idea come in and possibly flourish
and maybe the new idea doesn't even
prove your current belief system to be
wrong
but maybe it's like the the water to a
seed and it grows and now it's something
even bigger and better
yeah and you can you can start to work
with that instead
and it's a it's a tough thing because
i'm a stubborn [ __ ] and it's
very difficult for me it was
historically to say
i was wrong about this one or i messed
this one up or
yeah i wish i could have that one back
there's a public figure for me thing too
which there is there's a difference
between changing your mind with a small
circle of friends
and changing your mind publicly about
something
but it has equal it one echoes the other
it
is equally liberating but people um
people will not make that change easy uh
but it doesn't matter
that's that's the point it doesn't
i think it's ultimately liberating as a
human being public figure or not to uh
to think deeply about this world and uh
to keep changing
which is like i i think there's a deep
hunger for that in like political
discourse
that people are so tribal currently
about politics
that they want to see somebody who says
you know what i changed my mind on this
right and and then keep changing their
mind and keep asking questions keep
showing that they're open-minded all
that kind of stuff but
you want someone in a position of
political power
to change their mind because they
realize that there might be a better way
not because they realize that by
changing their mind they're going to get
a new demographic to vote for them
that's transparent as [ __ ] nobody wants
to see that right like
that's right that's a person who can't
separate their
their their position from their people
they're supposed to be helping yeah and
you can usually smell that that's
uh we're just talking uh offline about
uh
there's something about hillary clinton
where she talked about
changing her mind on gay marriage yeah
that it felt
like this is a political calculation
versus like
really deeply thinking about like what
you know what things do we do in this
world that violate
basic human rights like really thinking
about deeply and
you know of course politicians are
calculating there's but you can see it
you
this is the thing that's why i like um
as on the human level there's like
political policies but there's also
humans and i've always liked bernie
sanders for example
i don't know not the later perhaps
bernie sanders but i used to listen to
him back in the day
and never it felt that people might
disagree with me but it
it felt like there was a real human
struggling with ideas
whatever agree with him or not it felt
like he wasn't doing political
calculation he was just a human
he couldn't be further away from my
political ideals
but also like there's an obvious
authenticity
to his passion for what he's saying that
is not present in other candidates
and you could see it all these people
that have been in politics forever like
from
all the way back when hillary was a
lawyer in the 70s there's a couple of
shots of her in the courtroom in the 70s
though
she's looking all right she's got those
big glasses on
yeah kind of a little bit of a nerdy
babe back in the day
[Laughter]
wow john clark says hillary clinton was
a baby back in the day 73 hinton clinton
yeah
that's an interesting question about
authenticity and politicians do you
think
like uh hillary clinton just the
clintons in general are a good example
that
why do you think they become over time
so inauthentic
is it the system that changes them is it
their own hunger for power
is it uh what is it or they or were they
always inauthentic
well first i'd like to say that i don't
know if you know this but i come from a
bit of a political dynasty myself
uh i was on the student government
several times in high school and my dad
won um the runoff in a special election
in bradenton beach florida i think
there's like 700 people there
so so your dad got you the job yeah
we're basically
a lot of people compare us to the
kennedys my guess with the politicians
is that
and you can you can see it now as we're
becoming more like cognizant as people
to the political process
i think the process corrupts people and
i think that
i don't know the ins and outs of it i've
listened to people who are far more
educated on it than me and i
i'm unprepared to cite any of their
points
i think you can see it a little bit in
dan crenshaw can i say this
yeah so i like him i i really liked
dan especially like a year year and a
half ago he seemed
very level-headed it's clear to me now
that as he panders more and more to the
right it's because he's setting himself
up
for a presidential run it's clear that
that's happening
and he just doesn't seem like the same
authentic ideals
oriented guy that he did a year and a
half ago
now i could be wrong on that it could be
way off but i think that
you can take someone as honest as you
want to
when you start them on that path to the
presidency
you become so unbelievably beholden
to so many people and entities along the
way
that by the time you get to the the
final destination the oval office all
you're doing is paying back the favors
that got you there and you never get to
serve the people you're supposed to
serve
your your primary focus is on your
office and not on the people that you're
supposed to be helping
i think that that's a humongous problem
and like we could talk all about
campaign finance reform in the two-party
system but at the end of the day
the people who are running for political
posts
they're working to keep a job they're
not working to improve the lives of the
constituents which is different
a long long time ago like a lot of
politicians like those were like
part-time jobs
you know and they were they held other
posts and you know out west they were
ranchers by day
and sheriff by night whatever the case
might be but now
you have such a cushy path for the rest
of your life that the goal is to just be
a politician yeah not do the things that
you think a politician is supposed to do
and that's a problem by the way i'll
talk to dan on this
box it's funny i i like
the version of him from a year ago and i
haven't been really paying attention so
i'll be
i'll actually pay more attention now and
ask him that exact question like how do
you prevent
yourself from changing becoming what the
the clintons became
i tend to believe like there's
conspiratorial stuff about clinton's and
all these politicians that tend to
believe that they were actually
good thoughtful people back in the day
at some point and the system changes
them
on the it's not even the system
there's something about just the process
of campaigning
i just think it wears you down to where
if you look at the percentage of time
you spend on the kinds of conversations
you have
it's like one you do these speeches
which you repeat the same thing over and
over and over it beats
the uh the process of thinking you just
exhaust your brain to where you're not
thinking anymore you're just repeating
it's very
right it's exceptionally difficult to
keep making speech after speech
after speech saying the same thing over
and over and over again and at the same
time
thinking deeply and changing your mind
and learning and then also the
pandering to financial like having phone
calls like
fundraising all those kinds of things
that's what they do now they spend most
of their time fundraising they're not
worried about anything
sorry to interrupt you but i was going
to say that you can see there's a
fuel like the the more
attention and the higher regard you're
held in in your community
and the more sycophants like continue to
blow smoke up your ass
the more it changes the way you present
yourself and you can see it in in every
walk of life
i mean jiu-jitsu is a tiny tiny little
section of the world
but you see it in the jiu jitsu
community when someone all of a sudden
starts a social media page or whatever
and they get a bunch of people like
basically like you know
cyber fellating them on their instagram
page they
they changed a lady is that a word i
think so
so giving fellatio yeah it's afflating
yeah jamie look it up
i think but in those people they it
changes their character
yeah it changes who they are because
they become emboldened and
you know now they've got this like
mythical cyber mob behind them
there's a sign at the entrance to your
gym that reads for every moment of
triumph
it's a quote by hunter s thompson it
reads for every moment of triumph
for every instance of beauty many souls
must be trampled
what does this quote me do that quote to
me is about
mostly about sacrifice
and it's about to achieve anything great
or anything beautiful or to triumph you
have to have sacrificed
so many things to get there unless
you're the most unbelievably genetically
gifted person in the world
and greatness is just you know falls
upon you it's just raining from the sky
i think on your path to greatness on
your path to success and triumph
you leave a lot of carnage in your wake
personal relationships
other goals things that you didn't
pursue um
you know other unfulfilled dreams and
you kind of have to sell a lot of that
out
in order to be really the
at the the peak of your field or
or what you want to be um
i know that that's happened in my life i
mean there's tons and tons of
relationships that you know couldn't
survive
the way that i was living my life
because when i was trying to be a big
time fighter
or like when i was just training all the
time tons of relationships
uh dissolved themselves naturally some
not so naturally
some people get it some people don't get
it some people hate you
um you miss tons of other opportunities
and i think that's kind of what that
quote means to me it's about sacrifice
it's about
you're giving up what you want now for
what you want more
and it's the the trampling of souls
it's messy too because it's not clear
what
what the right path is like that
sacrifice
is not obvious that um that's those are
the right sacrifices to make you might
be
you might be ruining your own life but
the the fact that you're willing to take
that risk
and uh sort of go
all in on the whether it's stupid or not
to go all
in on something that the possib
the possibility of creating something
beautiful is there who says it's stupid
if you're going all in on it you don't
think it's stupid someone else might
think it's stupid
but i mean who really cares well i'm of
many minds on many things so i feel like
there's certain minds certain moods of
the day where you think it's stupid
like relationships is a beautiful one
which is you've seen the movie whiplash
by any chance yes
it seems like in a man's life
or it could be a woman's but i'm i don't
identify as a woman so i know the man
them the lyrics it's 20 20 bro but
my lived experience for now is that of a
man we'll see about tomorrow
and there is in the pursuit of
excellence
there's often a choice of
um some of the souls that must be
trampled are personal relationships
with humans in your life that you might
deeply care about it could be family it
could be friends
it could be loved ones of all different
forms
it could be the people that your
colleagues
that uh depended on you people who will
lose jobs because of the decisions you
make all this kind of stuff
it seems that that moment happens and
i'm not sure
that sacrifice is always the correct one
like to me the movie whiplash for people
haven't seen
a spoiler alert maybe i don't even know
if that movie has any
spoilers but there is a relationship
with a female
there's a student that's a drummer
that's pursuing excellence of this
particular
art form of drumming and he has
a brief fleeting relationship with a
female
and he also has an instructor that's
pushing him to his limits
in what appears to be awfully a lot like
a toxic relationship
and he chooses not chooses
he naturally makes the decision
to sacrifice the romantic relationship
with the woman
in in further pursuit of this chaos
of this chaotic pursuit of excellence
and it feel that doesn't feel like a
deliberate decision it feels like a
giant
mess of like an emotional mess where
you're just like
kind of like a fish swimming against
stream just like
[ __ ] it you let go of all the things
that
convention says you should appreciate
you you throw away the possibility of a
stable life of a comfortable life of uh
what society says is a meaningful life
and just pursue this crazy thing
full of toxic seeming toxicity with
crazy people surrounding you
i don't know so i don't know what the
right decision is like part of my brain
says you should stay with the girl
uh [ __ ] that instructor that's making
you
uh that's pushing you to to places where
it's like
that are destructive potentially
destructive like could lead to suicide
could lead you to uh completely
uh
fail or fail on your pursuit
of excellence or destroy the possibility
to destroy the dream
the passion or pursuit of the thing that
you've always dreamed for in that case
is drumming
i don't know i'm on many minds there
like what is the right thing to do
so my first two thoughts are number one
[ __ ] convention
what is convention it's like a some laid
out
path some linear progression of the way
your life is supposed to go
like you know that someone can draw a
picture of at the end that shit's
that first of all it's just boring and
whatever
and it's it's i don't want to say that
it's cowardly because it isn't cowardly
but for someone who's not conventional
to not be non-conventional
is cowardly to get sucked into the
convention that's first
second of all i believe
that scene in the diner in that movie
where he tells her yeah you're in my way
because
i'm gonna want to be with you or you're
going to want me to be going out to
dinner with you and i know i should be
practicing or i know
i should be training and ultimately i'm
going to make i'm either going to feel
bad about not being with you
by training or i'm going to skip the
training to be with you and neither one
is right
the whole thing that they don't mention
in that is that that's the wrong girl
that's the wrong girl
the right girl is a gangster the right
girl says
oh you you you've practiced tonight i'll
leave you a sandwich and some milk so
that you can
you know uh outside the door uh let me
know when you're done or you have some
like free time
like the right girl compliments that
she's not an impediment
in any way even if what you want to do
is
be with her so much that you're putting
the drums down you're putting the bass
down or you're picking up the pizza or
you're not going to training like
that girl without even telling you why
she's making decisions
is making decisions to help you achieve
your goal
now that might sound like some sort of
like chauvinistic king of the castle
type [ __ ] like where everyone should
cater to you
but the fact of the matter is uh
that person is a compliment to your life
and helping you do your thing
and in your own way you're helping them
to achieve whatever their goals are
also it's uncommon that you have two
people under the same roof
striving to be unbelievably excellent in
one small area it's not impossible but
it's uncommon
like relationships have to be like
binary systems like two stars
like the gravitational pull is what
keeps you together and circling around
one another right
and and you know one is bigger than the
other and they'll fluctuate and you know
the stars will get bigger and they'll
get smaller and they're contract
based on positioning and you know
composition
that that's the way a relationship
should be not an asteroid coming in
to disrupt you know your the the surface
of your planet yeah it's a binary system
it's a compliment that girl was the
wrong girl for him
so you shouldn't uh like the big
unconventional dreams
should not be adjusted to fit into this
world because i mean there is a part of
me that's like full of salt out well
maybe you're just a dick
maybe maybe who cares lex so
first of all who cares
this is uh by the by the way somebody
who's uh
you have you have recently gotten well
recently
in the span of the history of the
universe is recently you got into a
relationship but you haven't always
you have not felt the need to be
in the relationship just because you're
supposed to by society's kind of
momentum if you i think that if you
really want anything
you've got to be prepared fully to be
the exact opposite
if you're a person who's looking for a
relationship the only way you're going
to get in an awesome relationship is by
being comfortable being alone
yeah because that's the risk if you're a
person who's driven by money you've got
to be comfortable being totally poor
because that's the risk right and when
you're when
when you're when you're constantly
hedging your bets you're never
all in you're never all in on the thing
you're trying to do
um a relationship has to complement your
life you can't say
it's okay to want to be in a
relationship but you can't want to be in
a relationship so bad
that you take someone in who fits the
suit and it's like oh
our schedules kind of work out you live
near me and this and the other thing
because the logistics of a relationship
are not always perfect
it's what matters is when the two people
are together that's the perfect part of
it
and it's great to want to meet people
and say if we meet and
some sort of a relationship develops i'm
willing to run with it
but i'm not meeting you hoping a
relationship develops
i think you kind of put the cart before
the horse in a lot of those
situations it's like when guys meet like
no guy goes out and is like i'm looking
for a bro
right nobody does that you go to the gym
and you run into a bunch of dudes and
the next thing you know someone's cool
and they want to talk about fighting
and you're [ __ ] shotgun and beers and
all of a sudden you got a bro yeah and
that's how it works it works the same
same way with what's the shotgun and
beers um i'll show you after this
you poke a hole in the bottom and you
open the top
yeah this is the problem with america
drink vodka like a man okay now don't
poke holes in beers
this is the problem with the frat
culture they don't really know how to
drink they think they know how to drink
they don't know how to drink
what do you think
makes a successful relationship if we
can linger on that a little longer
like let me ask
john clark about love
i didn't ask a question but let me just
say love
about love
uh are you one of those people who never
says i love you no
no i'm an extreme person and uh like my
emotions are also extreme
and one of the things uh i concern
myself with
maybe this is philosophical and martial
arts warrior soldier type related stuff
is like
i don't want anyone if i die tonight on
the drive home
hopefully that doesn't happen i hope
that no one is
left questioning how i felt about them
and people i don't like probably are not
questioning that
and so the the thing that i've had to
learn how to do later in life is to tell
the people that
you care about that you care about them
and um each thing can be equally
off-putting to the receiver of the
message
each thing can be equally upgraded when
you're letting someone know how much you
dislike them that can be off-putting to
the person receiving that message
and when you tell someone how much you
care about them it can also be
off-putting to the person
depending on how they view their
relationship with you but it's still
important to get it out there
like you shouldn't you shouldn't hold
those things in because you're worried
about how they'll be received or if
they'll come back at you
so you're okay going all in yeah on
these
yeah you're not afraid of commitment no
i'm not afraid of commitment anyone who
says they're afraid of commitment is
full of [ __ ] you know what they're
afraid of
they're afraid of commitment with that
person that's what they're afraid of
like you no one when someone knocks your
your
knocks you on your ass and they come
into your life and you're
flush with all these emotions you're not
worried about
oh i don't really like commitment no
because they've knocked you on your ass
you want to be with them
you want those things the the two most
alive
points in your life i think people feel
is the euphoria of a new relationship
and the law and then the loss when that
love is gone
you know you'll never feel more i don't
think than in those
those moments in in your life see the
nice thing about the loss
is it lasts longer
yeah that's a lose ck
point that he makes which is like uh
that like uh he in his show i think has
a
conversation with an older gentleman
that says like that's his favorite part
of the relationship
is that period between the loss
of the relationship and the real death
which is forgetting the person but that
period lasts the longest and that's the
like the most fulfilling like missing
the other person
is as fulfilling as the actual like
love the the early infatuation which is
interesting i also think of the bukowski
i returned to that there's a little clip
of him in an interview
saying that love is a
fog that dissipates
with the first light of reality or
something like that so
basically emphasizing that it's this
very very very fleeting thing
that it's a it's a moment's thing
and then it just fades and everything
else is uh
is something else so love is only a
temporary thing which is
interesting i think some people say
that's cynical
i don't know i don't know what to think
of it i think it's important to
understand that everything is fleeting
when you don't put effort into it
almost everything will be fleeting if
you don't put effort into it most people
will get fat and lazy if you don't put
effort into something you're going to
not be
good at uh playing guitar or playing
bass you've got to put effort into it
the same thing goes for a relationship
that the the awesome part of it
that like love part that dies soon and
early on in a relationship
because it's so good that we think we
don't have to work at it
but you do you have to like keep doing
the things you got to keep things
new and crisp and fresh and you know
when you
when you different people probably feel
differently
about this but like i don't know you
walk around your girl and you start like
farting and stuff like that's when it
all dies
yeah that's when it dies you know we're
all human beings
we all you know have you know we're all
here and our bodies working the same way
but like
you start to chip away at this like
beautiful thing
when you when you stop
when you buck conventional courtesy
and and things like that well take it
for granted basically take it for
granted yeah i mean that's the same
thing with life
it's like it's the same i'm a big fan of
meditating on
death that you could die today in the
same way you should meditate on like
this relationship could end today this
connection with another human could be
this is the last time you could uh
you could be interacting yeah and your
your chances of that increase when you
take it for granted and you [ __ ] on
people
but when you work at it the chances of
that decrease it's not
it's never going to be zero but it
decreases and and
when you do that when you're the person
and you're you're trying to maintain
and you're trying to you know work at
the relationship you got to make sure
that both people are working at it
otherwise you're just a [ __ ] chump
okay let's uh return back to uh mixed
martial arts
let me ask the ridiculous question of uh
who do you think are the top
three maybe top five greatest fighters
of all time
it's so hard to compare fighters across
generations and maybe on one way to say
it is which metrics
would you put on the table as to measure
what a great fighter is
there was a guy named dioccipus
[Laughter]
in the fourth century yeah and he was
such a badass
that in the olympics in 336 bc no one
even showed up to fight him
in the pancreatic event nobody even
showed up because he's [ __ ] everybody
up
years later he was retired and uh this
crazy macedonian dude came there at some
dinner for
you know alexander the great everyone's
chilling drinking you know whatever they
were drinking out of their
chalices and this macedonian dude
threatened him and challenged him so
dioccipus said yeah man
we'll throw down and you know they set
the time in the place macedonian dude
comes out like
body armor spear shield all this other
[ __ ]
the octopus came out absolutely naked
with a wooden club
and took on this much younger guy beat
the living crap out of him and then put
his foot on his throat
uh and then didn't even kill him in the
show of ultimate power
for the time so i think there's
something about the guy being naked too
it's just
extra demeaning extra demeaning yeah
okay
can we rephrase the question then
because those are clearly going to be
some probably forgotten warriors in
history let's take it to like modern day
mixed martial arts in the ufc perhaps
well
just mixed martial arts there who do you
think are the top fighters of all time
what metrics would you consider in in
trying to answer this perhaps
unanswerable question i think one of the
things you want to think about is a
strength of opponent at the time you
fought them
so for example fighting bj penn
in his prime and beating him is far
different than beating bj penn last year
right
so to say you have a victory over bj
penn it's not the same given the time
frame of when it happened not to take
anything away from anyone was being b.j
penn
just use that as an example of someone
whose career went into a different
direction
yes i would say
the guy who i think is probably the best
that people are the least familiar with
would be marilla bustamante
and i think he was a guy who was one of
the guys with the first
really good physical build for mma which
i think is
narrow from the chest to the back and
long shoulder to shoulder
and kind of sinewy made out of steel
cable that was a guy who could box
that was a guy who could wrestle and
that was a guy who had great jiu-jitsu
i wasn't a great kick but at the time he
didn't need it
fought everybody and gave everybody a
run
uh i think he's probably one of those
guys who's
got to be considered yeah there's a few
killers that never
because like why is he not in the
discussion is it because like
i think greatness requires
both the the skill and the opportunity
to meet each other and when you talk
about a fighter the other thing
that really a good fighter needs to
become great is a foil
yeah and so many fighters don't have a
foil
that's one of the biggest attractions i
think of early mike tyson's career
he didn't have a foil he had no one
driving him and by the time he did by
the time he had a foil in holyfield
his career was in a different place but
he he's one of the greats of all time he
never really
had a foil so his greatness was in the
un unparalleled destruction of like
nobody right well not you know
uh of lesser opponents right and so when
people
uh debate the you know the level of
greatness of mike tyson that's one of
the things they say like he didn't fight
a lot of killers in their prime i think
you've obviously got to say in that
conversation
i have a really difficult time keeping
george st pierre out of the
conversation uh only because
he was able to beat you with anything he
could he could
out jab you he could out wrestle you and
he could he could submit you
the problem i have with fedor is his
career also took
a drastic turn towards the end
and when he was fighting in pride he was
doing a lot more grappling
and then he just started casting that
overhand right at people
and his game kind of changed at that
point uh he can't take anything away
from his greatness but
at that time the great heavyweights were
not really
uh in fighting in pride and they didn't
really exist yet and by the time he
fought a really good one fabrizio over
doom
he did get submitted there does does his
later
performance color our your and our
perception
of his greatness like in general about
fighters
not mine but i'm someone who's like
intimately involved in the sport
but it colors everyone else's same with
anderson silva like i don't think
anderson
doesn't want to fight in like seven
years or something or he's like one like
that's a guy who in his prime was one of
the best fighters
is he in the top five for you i think
he's probably in a top five yeah
greater striker of all time or no in mma
and
in mixed martial arts and mixed martial
arts
that's a tough question the greatest mma
striker
of all time because like the timing the
we were talking about foot sweeps right
yeah who makes it look
easier and uh anderson zilla i think
in an incredibly short sample of his
prime
it's got to be anderson silva and i
think you have to consider discussing
leota machida
for his unbelievable manipulation of
distance
yeah which is something that people
don't really talk too much about in
terms of fighting unless you're someone
in the sport
yeah the his his use of distance and the
ability to like
what we call pop out like and make you
miss by one inch
so that he could follow your fist back
in as you retract it and
hit you over the top that
that's a thing of beauty anderson silva
when he became a counter striker
when he got to his prime in the ufc that
was a thing of beauty that was the thing
of beauty
um so i think definitely those two guys
and maril bustamanti's got to be
the third guy they're just so many good
guys now so
where do you put in terms of metrics as
you mentioned gsp and anderson silva i
think they have a large number of
defenses of a title
is that important to you like this kind
of consistent
domination no because it's too much it's
easily easily manipulated by the people
making money off the fights
so there's a great quote one time uh
when ufc was coming to prominence
and uh vince mcmahon from the wwe he
said
you know the difference between what we
do and what uh ufc does
is that when we have a superstar
i can make sure he stays on top until
he's no longer a superstar because we
have predetermined results
yeah the ufc can't do that because
they're actually having fights well it's
true and false you can't do that but you
can give
your superstars the most favorable
match-ups to keep them on top for the
longest
so people always talk about title
defenses as if the guy they're fighting
the challenger is always the person most
deserving of the shot
and it's just not true so i don't put
that much stock in it
is it possible to put a guy in the in um
in consideration of one of the greats if
all they had
is one or two amazing fights
i'll tell you like and and amazing could
be
a lot of different definitions it could
be just a war like they never really
reached
the highest of excellences of domination
but
they've like this we had this discussion
about
kyle bochniak right yep
uh to me that's the perfect example he
had this famous
fight uh against the beat
magametr sharapov
where you on one side you have an
anderson silva type of fighter
and ends to be like just a very good
striker
like and then there's like the warrior
on the
on the kyle's side and just the fight
they created something special together
it was fight at night whatever but the
you know that fight was special
on that night because because the two
dance partners
you can have a great performance without
being a great fighter not saying neither
of those guys is a great fighter but to
answer your first question
uh i think that having one or two great
performances
does not necessarily mean that you're
great when i need a larger sample size
i have no idea what that is i don't have
any idea what that is and also
where how much weight does toughness
have when you're thinking about the
criteria when you define a great fighter
that's that's that's a good question and
i don't have the answer to it
i admire the underdog that rises to the
occasion through brute force
they didn't have they didn't bring the
skill set to the table that
perhaps some of the greats have but they
rose to the occasion i mean there's
something about that there's something
about that and so now
we're more talking about like uh the
internal attributes as opposed to the
external physical attributes
and those are the things i think that
you cannot teach
those things you you come in the door
and you either have that or you don't i
think
and we talk about this all the time and
this is one of the things where my mind
changes
regularly like i'm what makes a fighter
is it is it born or is it bread
and this week i'm of the opinion that uh
it's in you and maybe it's in you and
you suppress it and people can tease it
out of you
but i don't think you can make someone
who doesn't have that seed in there
i don't think you can turn them into
that great warrior with that level of
grit
and mental toughness now when that that
fight
when kyle footes a beat it's a unique
situation for both guys
it was kind of a later later replacement
fight for kyle
it's a beats star was on the rise and
kyle put the blueprint out there
on how to beat the beat um which is
which is uh pressure him and try and
drag him into the late rounds you notice
that
later on when uh calvin kater fought him
they wouldn't give him five rounds
they wanted five rounds and it's a beats
camp from what i understand would not
agree to the five round fight
well he didn't look right so with kylo
was a
three-round fight three-round fight and
what did uh
he went to decision it went to decision
was a beat one a decision clearly
did kyle have a shot of winning the
third round i don't remember the exact
score but kyle could have
won the third round had he done a couple
things
differently but i do believe in the
fourth round
i think kyle would have won a fourth
round and i think maybe even won the
fight and
if there would have been a fifth round
and he was pressing forward
uh like perhaps you know in a funny way
that you could
tell me i'm wrong but it felt like he
wasn't emphasizing like
head movement at that point he went full
mike tyson there was a there was a point
at which
so it's funny that you say that which is
a contradiction actually because
mike tyson had a great headache i
actually don't know exactly what i mean
because he was in the pocket i think he
was trying to do the movement he was
just in the pocket
and pressing forward and like the [ __ ]
you attitude it was just like yeah
that was a little bit later once it
beats backwards towards the cage but
the we we get that fight and
i said to kyle i was like look this kid
has been training martial arts since he
was three years old
there's not an area where you're gonna
out technique him and so we've gotta now
channel some of that grit that we know
you have this is an opportunity to
showcase it
and i don't know how long i did it for
but um because kyle's much
shorter than the beat so for a good long
while while we're training for zabeet i
didn't even say anything
and i just had clips of mike tyson
training on the tv in the gym
and the head movement and i didn't even
mention it and then we started to like
get into it
and talk about you know getting inside
the length of the longer fighter and
uh things like that and we we kind of
which
when some people train mma they say okay
this guy's a really good wrestler
let's think about avoiding the wrestling
or being a better wrestler and i think
that
when the difference in skill is so great
those are both the wrong answer
if a guy who's a really good wrestler
wants to take you down and you don't
have a lot of wrestling experience he's
probably going to get you down if he's
got a good coach
right so you have to deal with that to
then say i'm gonna then
learn in eight weeks how to wrestle
better than a guy who's been wrestling
since he was eight years old is also a
bad idea
so what we concentrated on for that camp
and it worked beautifully was
not getting caught in chain wrestling
these are the takedowns you're going to
get caught with
this is how to not get caught with the
next step while you're defending take
down one
because it's the chain of techniques
that are going to get you [ __ ] right
so we talked we did a ton of work on get
ups and breaking the hands from
the various takedowns like it was a
while ago now so i don't remember
exactly the techniques we worked on but
we concentrated on
defend the first takedown and stay out
of the chain don't get chained into
a bunch of wrestling techniques because
you will be out wrestled um
and that was really successful and then
in the third round uh beat was tired
and uh he was tired he's a beat got
tired he cuts a tremendous amount of
weight yeah like i
i can't see him staying at 145 forever
when they start giving him
five round fights i don't even know if
he's had a five-round fight yet he may
have but
um i i can't see him staying down there
he's the guy's like six
one yeah guys he's he's a giant of a guy
so
kyle pressed forward there and he said
uh he felt that there was no power left
in zabeet's hands and so he felt fine
and i think part of it was he fed off
the crowd as he moved forward
and um you know saw that
he wasn't taking a lot of damage like
the punches weren't standing him
he started walking right through him it
goes to your question of what makes a
fighter
was the him walking forward
like that something that you're born
with or is that something you were
training is that
is that the mike tyson on tv born with
that kyle is born with that
and the crowd i i've been in boston
no he's in new york he's in brooklyn
i've been in a lot of arenas for a lot
of different sporting events that's one
of the loudest things i've ever heard
when he did that and i was going crazy
and um
you ask about that being like taught or
not kyle is so much like that
that i have to try and tease some of
that out of him and pull it back
because he's also so very technical when
he wants to be
that the emotion and the fun of it gets
in the way of his technique
and and probably has cost them a couple
of a couple of wins and so that's one of
the things we work on with him right now
is like staying within yourself
being a professional taking your time to
download the information in round one
and then starting your fight in round
two but the tension between those two
things what makes
uh what on that day created one of the
in my opinion one of the greatest fights
i've ever seen joe rogan agrees yeah
it's one of the greatest fights i've
certainly ever seen
so like i you it's funny that you as a
coach
i can see the frustration of like
like throwing away some of the strategy
kind of thing
like you seeing like being not happy
that there could be things that he could
have done to win the fight
it's in retrospect i think that at that
time we were playing with incredible
house money
kyle was a gigantic underdog in that
fight his beat was unstoppable i think
people were probably picking him to
finish the fight in round one
i think at that point no one had ever
gone the distance with the beat yeah and
no one certainly had
you know put that kind of performance
together and i think kyle uh kyle put
the blueprint out there
and in retrospect when i look at the
last round
yeah there were things that could have
been done differently but we're playing
with house money at that point like i
mean
let it fly you you get to a point where
you've got it you're down three rounds
and there's 20 seconds left you got to
move all your chips to the center of the
table and
you know see what happens do you
remember what joe rogan said about it
i i remember like he got one over i
think
i have trouble remembering because
offline we talked about that fight and
he's exceptionally impressed by
i mean joe's from boston so it's like
yeah
i mean there there's a story there okay
it sucks not you naturally want to
romanticize
like there's a rocky versus like uh
there's a rocky four
dragon i mean um similar i suppose
kind of chemistry kyle's style
represents the american ideal
right the spirit yeah i mean he's from
gloucester it's like you could have
you could have dragged him off the docks
like three hours before the fight and
said hey you want to go fight and he
would have said yes
yeah oh man that was a special fight but
that's
as per discussion of like greatest
fighters of all time i tend
to believe that that fight is more
special than the
the the champion the championship belt
defense is by george san pierre like
you know there's something to that it's
like rocky um
rocky one is uh is more special than
like
rocky iii right so like yeah it's
though that yeah the the underdog or
it's whatever like the dance partners
like going to war
and like that moment i mean it's bigger
it's bigger than any individual fighter
they create that and that i know it's
not perhaps
good for a career it's not good for like
in terms of money in terms of longevity
in terms of all those kinds of things
but that's a special moment
in the history of fighting that you both
created i can remember
like right after like there was so much
excitement in the air during the third
round
and i remember being in the corner and
like i i was so
excited at the end of it that i had
forgotten what happened in the other two
rounds i didn't even know and
and i looked to to sean one of the other
cornermen and i think i said to him
did we win when we re-watched the fight
clearly we didn't win the fight i mean
we lost the other rounds but i got so
caught up
in that moment and then i just remember
like i was
so in awe of his performance that like i
forgot what was going on and i
i and it's so hard to not be a fan at
that moment and to stay within yourself
and try and like coach
but then what the [ __ ] you even coaching
at that point it's like we're rumbling
we got 30 seconds we're trying to win
here and i remember
like the performance itself i'm not a
fan of moral victories but if ever there
was going to be one that was one
and when the fight was over and i
grabbed kyle
they hadn't even been to the center of
the cage yet and i just hugged him and i
said
you're my [ __ ] hero and i remember
being very emotional about that that i
was able to be a part of that
it feels wrong to say but i was i kind
of avoided saying it but if i'm being
honest with my feelings
this is a safe space for feelings yeah
is i
think it was the greatest mixed martial
arts fight i've ever seen and i don't
think i'm being biased i was honestly
thinking like am i being biased i
honestly
don't think so i think that was the
greatest fight like if you want to rank
fights i've ever seen
i think to me that was the greatest
fight i've ever seen it certainly was a
uh one of the greatest displays of like
just
dogged effort from an underdog who was
out experienced and and probably
outsized
but i mean like you just kyle's one of
those kids you're never gonna tell him
he's out of a fight
he has something you can't teach and
i've seen
tons of people with more physical
attributes
and they're just mental midgets and they
got a million dollar body and a 50 cent
heart
and and and kyle is not that yeah and
you can't teach it no matter what you do
but that was i would say like my career
in combat sports which spans you know if
you want to go all the way back to like
wrestling like
that was one of probably the greatest
experiences i've i've been a part of a
bittersweet sport she's a fickle
mistress
yeah i mean the the tragic aspect of
that is
um like i guess kyle lost
right right so like if you look at the
record and all the kind of things
perhaps uh like you look at the career
maybe like as a financial
from a financial perspective that
perhaps is not uh
the the greatest thing for carl's career
or
that or in in the history of the ufc
perhaps it's not
it's not um you know like maybe many
people didn't even watch that fight
but it was a special moment that stands
in the history there's not many of these
in uh in the history of fighting so but
at the end of the day when you look at
someone's career in the ufc like
financially there's a you know a handful
of people that make real money
everybody else makes nothing there's a
handful of people that make real money
so did that loss cost him in the in the
near term sure
but when you look back on your life
you're not going to look back on that
loss as something that derailed my life
financially and i never
recovered from it that's not going to
happen like the sad thing is
unless you were a champion and you know
most most people are going to be
forgotten right after they're gone
most people will be forgotten and if
you're not forgotten certainly your
your accolades are going to be
misrepresented either they're going to
be inflated or diminished one way or the
other so
looking back on it it's just so hard to
to quantify that but it's an experience
and like
when you're in that moment and you're
one of the people like
intimately involved in it like the value
of that experience
supersedes any financial gain
where would you put khabib in the
discussion of the greatest of all time
so you recently we worked together we
watched the fight
um of him and um justin gaichy
and and khabib retired would you put him
up there
as some of the as one of the greatest or
did he
never truly find his foil that like the
great warrior that challenged him
and um and maybe do you wanna do you
think he's
fully retired now to answer the question
about being fully retired i don't have
any idea i can't for a second pretend
to um
think that i understand the way that
people from that part of the world think
and respect their family and things like
that to an american who says oh i
promised my mom i wouldn't do it i mean
i promised my mom i wouldn't do a lot of
things i went right out [ __ ] back
door and did them yeah
but i think that that means something
different to people in different parts
of the world
so i have no idea what kind of weight
that carries
so i can't answer that i can say
a lot of times when people think about
great fighters they think about the
aspects that make up
mma like they think of mma as a pie
and they're all these different pieces
that make up for make up the pie
and how good is this piece and how good
is this piece and how good is this piece
when the fact of the matter is is you
only need
one really really really good piece and
the other pieces are complementary
pieces to get you
to where you're the strongest and if you
want to tell me
that khabib's not the greatest mma
fighter because he doesn't have really
slick striking
you can make that argument but what i
can tell you is khabib has good enough
striking
to get him to his grappling where he is
clearly the best guy at 155 they've ever
seen
yeah so does that make him the greatest
fighter at that division or not
to your point about the foil they wanted
conor to be his foil
and he just manhandled them i mean they
wanted that to happen
did not happen so well there there's a
kind of argument to be made
which would kind of not you get haters
in this argument
and and you're going to be one of the
haters okay because i know you're uh
uh put a lack of uh admiration for
conor mcgregor uh but
you know uh what is it football's the
game of inches
yeah there's there's a sense where
you know that conor there's an argument
to be made
that conor wasn't exactly dominated that
he ended up being dominant meaning
let me phrase it differently is there's
a lot of points
in the fight that it could have uh a
different trajectory
right could have happened so he wasn't
so far from
having a chance at winning that fight
it's just the end
you can focus those are the most
important moments at the end
you've lost the most important moments
right but the road less taken it could
have been
if he didn't lose those very important
moments
he had a chance so i'm saying out of all
the people that could be
fought it's arguable that conor was up
there of the people that had a chance
let me say this first
i love you get so much heat for this i
do love khabib i'm a huge khabib fan
because i'm a grappler
first and foremost me too because i'm
also russian i love khabib
calm down okay but when when when connor
came on the scene i loved conor because
i'm an irish american and
you know i want to support him and
things like that and he was he was good
fun
he he got to be for my personal
taste he got to be too much of all the
people khabib has fought
i would never fight conor again if i
were him and here's why
and i said this about the diaz fight
nate diaz who's one of my favorite
fighters has fought the exact same fight
for 12
years conor will switch something up to
give himself an edge
and i believe that conor would figure
something out in fight number two
i think but i also thought that gage
would give could be problems
where it wouldn't be a matter of i'm
gonna out wrestle khabib or
become better at defending his wrestling
takedowns conor would have figured out a
way to not get wrestled
i feel like he's constantly changing
he's constantly evolving
and whether or not people realize it or
not i think conor's one of the better
overall
athletes in mma just from looking at his
body and his movement
and the way he's shaped he's got a very
tiny waist he's got really pronounced
glutes and shoulders
and i think he's a real athlete whereas
a lot of guys in mma are not for real
athletes they're just good at
one of the things that makes up mma i
understand what you're saying about
if this happened if that happened but i
mean you could say that about
every single combat sports event ever if
spinx's hook land
landed on tyson maybe that fight didn't
end the way that it did
but you know what it didn't you're
absolutely right but
if we could talk about just conor
mcgregor for a second
i can't wait to get your fan mail or
hate mail
um speak to the innovation of conor
i don't hear very many people making
this argument
but is it possible to make an argument
that conor mcgregor is one of the
greatest fighters of all time
it's an interesting argument and the
problem the only problem with the
argument
is there's so much emotion on either
side yeah i had a conversation sorry to
interrupt
with uh jaron brook who's a
a philosopher objectivist and
which is the philosophy of iron rand and
the amount of
emotion around that particular human is
fascinating to me it's similar to
the amount of emotion around donald
trump you can think of different
personalities maybe elon musk
those are the people that aren't willing
to have their mind changed they're too
emotionally attached to the argument
yeah but it's weird that why do we why
why some people inspire so much emotion
and others don't but conor mcgregor i
feel like
nobody's able to have a calm like
uh fight analysis of the guy like
look to me as just a fan of
martial arts like i study judo i love
watching just hours of
olympic judo and uh appreciating the art
form like i forget the humans involved
uh teddy renair who's a heavy
heavyweight the most probably the most
dominant heavyweight
in the history of judo just studying his
gripping just the art of it
and who cares if there's [ __ ] talking
like to me um
i i put all of that aside and just look
at the art
and like what i really appreciate about
conor mcgregor
is his innovation like
of movement of maybe it's romanticized
maybe
you can correct me i'm just uh a cheeto
eating fan
of mixed martial arts but like i i seem
to detect
more innovation than almost any other
fighter
uh that i've pa pay attention to in
conor mcgregor i think first to i'll
answer in two parts i think
well i'm not going to answer the first
part it's just a comment because you
didn't ask the question
what was the question i don't even
remember it's about the the
how conor mcgregor fans are very
emotional and conor mcgregor detractors
are very emotional
i think fans become very emotional they
become cheerleaders of someone like
conor mcgregor or donald trump because
they see that person exhibiting the
qualities that they themselves lack
and so they become cheerleaders for that
right and i think that for the most part
people who are detractors of conor
mcgregor's they're not really conor
mcgregor detractors
they're detractors of connor's
supporters there's a beef that they have
with the people in that bucket
right like it's not really a problem and
that applies probably
in our current political climate right
with donald trump with the left and the
right there it's more about like
they uh they actually don't like
on the other the caricatured the most
extreme versions of
what they see in this quarters of the
other side yeah that's a good point but
i think the more interesting thing is
the fighter himself so let's put the
supporters aside
i would i would say that you know
what some people know and some people
don't know is that conor's base is in
karate and the karate
style of conor mcgregor stephen thompson
um
of lyoto machida that type of distance
management
a lot of times we think as martial
artists we think that
the sport version of the art we've
chosen to pursue
somehow taints the authenticity in the
in the
effectiveness of it but point karate is
what led to that in and out distance
management style
of connor of leota and of stephen
thompson they all kind of use it a
little bit differently
but they use it very effectively all
three of them and that comes from
a world of trying to kind of like
uh step in land contact on you from my
point and then get back out before you
can counter-strike me
right and that's where that comes from
conor is blessed to have
longer arms than someone his height
probably normally has
and his movement is just so fluid he's
so athletic with
uh the hinges of his body the knees and
the hips
and the swivel of his body which is also
the hips and the shoulders
his movement his distance and the way he
sets people up for the straight left
hand
while you're circling away from it and
he can still land it which is what he
did to chad mendes
hit him with a straight left while he
was circling away from it
that is something that is uh very
beautiful to watch
and sometimes people see the kicks
and they see all the flashy snap kicks
and the sidekicks
all that stuff is doing is setting
people up for the left hand
it's all it's doing it's you're
corralling people you're funneling
people or you're leading the dance
and you're bringing them to a spot where
you know you can land that left hand
and his ability to do that is masterful
people constantly [ __ ] on his ability to
grapple and you know because a couple of
his losses have been
uh to jiu jitsu guys or grapplers but
they've been to really good guys
like anyone who's gonna sit here and
tell me conor mcgregor is not a good
grappler
go grapple him yeah let me see you
grapple him
to that point i'll also say a lot of
people will use conor mcgregor's x-guard
sweep on nate diaz as evidence
to his high-level grappling in that
fight to which i would also counter
nate diaz didn't fight that off because
he knew he was so much better at
jiu-jitsu off the bottom that he didn't
even care if he got swept
so is conor mcgregor innovative
absolutely
um is he one of the best fighters ever
it's tough to say because he's such a
cash cow that he was fed people
i firmly believe no one who
who put that conor mcgregor khabib fight
together thought khabib would win
wow i i remember so at that time
it was not completely clear there was a
myth
of the great khabib right it wasn't
completely clear how good is he really
so that's interesting and it was unclear
how
good is conor also right like what
uh because because i think to me
maybe part of my admiration of conor
mcgregor is rooted in the fact that i
thought there's no way
he beats jose aldo and i thought there's
no
definitely no way he beats eddie alvarez
and so like when he did
uh i was like i had to like my i had to
my brain was like like there's something
broken it was like shut down like on
windows like froze we have to rethink
this
like this is a special human now people
who argue he's not even in the running
of like
top 20 is you know if you look at the
number of defenses for example of his
belt
he had very very little but like to me
i'm one of those people is back to our
discussion of like
do moments make great fighters that i
think just being able to beat jose aldon
is
i would argue in his prime some people
might disagree
in this uh
in in a way where he like figures out
the puzzle gets in his head the entirety
of the picture
and then to be i mean eddie alvarez
would he be considered a really good
strong wrestler
like like or uh not not strong wrestling
strong striker and wrestler that could
the whole combination of it and also uh
what's the other wrestler he fought chad
mendes chairman so
let me comment on all those if i may so
i was at the chad mendez fight live
yeah and um there was a jiu jitsu
tournament we're out in vegas and so me
my best friend came out and we got some
tickets that night was supposed to be
the first
aldo fight aldo got hurt like right
after i bought the tickets
they pulled chad mendes in he was a
little bit out of shape whatever you
still got to fight the fight
but i don't i don't want to use that
fight as evidence to conor's greatness
because you know they pulled chad mendez
and all he was like hunting and drinking
beers in the woods
and was a little out of shape yeah but
if you want to talk about greatness like
that surpasses
your in-ring accomplishments
i was in the stands that night and
the people that came from ireland to see
connor fight that night
single-handedly set the market for hotel
room prices and airline tickets to vegas
that weekend these [ __ ] were
all dressed like connor
in the stands they had wool suits on and
big beards and the whole thing i mean
probably wearing pocket watches like i
never saw more people
trying to be someone else never saw more
people try to be someone else
i mean there's a level of is is there a
level of greatness in that i mean i
don't know how to
like parse all that out you're somebody
who doesn't admire that i love that
in the sense the following sense i think
that people don't seem to hold this
belief at all
but to me fighting is not just
this isn't like a quiet street fight
that nobody watches this is also
spectacle this is also a story
right there's like there's a
professional wrestling element to this
this is not
like you you think it's it's just about
fighting if it was just about fighting
you wouldn't i mean there's a story to
it i guess
you're trying to get to it and like
greatness has to incorporate that
like people that criticize again i might
be wrong on this but i i honestly think
that
uh conor mcgregor not nearly as much as
khabib but he he's a true
martial artist i think he respects his
opponents despite the talk
i if maybe i'm misreading it but it
feels like
he is a storyteller like uh jail son
and type of like he's constructed this
image
to tell to uh to play the story like
just the way he acts
after the fight the honor he shows his
opponents
yeah there's a real martial art in there
and to dismiss the fact that
uh the the the story of the fight is
part of it
because he doesn't just [ __ ] talk this
is what people don't seem to understand
he's good at [ __ ] talking very good and
i and i'm with you on
on basically everything you said i think
that there's greatness to that and i
think that he understands how to sell a
fight
and i think
what he did to jose aldo by getting in
his head
helped him win that fight
he insulted jose aldo and his country so
much
that he knew aldo was going to come
forward right into that left hook
was that fighting in brazil by the way
do you remember i don't recall because i
know
he insulted all of brazil yeah i'm not
sure yes in brazil
but when he tried to do that to khabib
you could tell that he just was not
going to get in khabib's head khabib was
unflappable
but there is there is definitely
something great about
how he moves people you know the irish
are
are like i mean conor's walkout music
like for people from ireland and of
irish descent like
that [ __ ] is like very deep yeah you
know that
it's very emotional song i was
to be honest a little bit upset with
khabib
that he didn't rise i admire
that entire culture but there's an
aspect to where he could have risen to
the occasion of
there's the same kind of depth of
love of country that russia has
and uh is there in dagestan dagestan is
a little weird
in terms of like but he could have
especially with putin's support where
for a bit
the full russian hat right of like this
is the great nation like rise above
the uh the culture of dagestan which is
a small town boy with the small
town values of family and all those
kinds of things there's a moment where
you
inspire entire nations like
the step up and be the foil to the
to to the great conor mcgregor
where also could be becomes the fall to
like
like both both of them at the fall to
each other and become like
that fight was already a great fight
right but it could have been
something historic ali versus freight i
mean it could have been
really historic and i would argue
i guess the biggest disappointment i
have and i understand it and i also
honor as a martial artist
but to i'm disappointed that khabib
doesn't seem to even consider the
possibility of doing in moscow
fight number two so and because that
could be
narrative wise if they do it right
that's one of the
could be one of the greatest fights in
history
yeah i think in terms of khabib
and inspiring a country
is it possible that by staying true to
the values that he had his entire career
and getting to the zenith of
of his art form and still doing it in
that humble way isn't it possible that
that inspires
yeah 100 so i should i should clarify
that i think
they're just hearing from people from my
my fellow comrades
no uh it's they love that they love
they love that but they uh
there's also a brash beer chugging [ __ ]
talking thing that people really like
about connor and i i do love that
but the beautiful narrative would have
been the clash the real clash of those
cultures so
khabib chooses to live the culture by
walking away
there's also like a clash of them sort
of
walking not walking away from the fire
by walking
into the fire of this of this brashness
it's the
sort of um the cool
collected like calmness of the dagestan
people it's like you were talking about
the saita brothers so
they just view it totally differently
and
you know there are stereotypes about the
irish where they're
maybe potentially a louder more
boisterous culture
and i haven't heard of that yet yeah and
i mean i thought they each played
their part perfectly and
all those things that you're describing
could have happened maybe khabib steps
up and
he carries the proverbial flag so to
speak for a nation of people
and they go to battle but the fight if
it plays out the same way is still the
fight
yeah and it was a it was an okay fight
it wasn't a great fight
it was you know the fight was okay yeah
and i think that again
i don't have any idea what khabib's
obligations to his family are
i don't i don't think either those guys
you know is
want for more money to do another fight
is just a legacy thing it's just about
uh
you know fulfilling some some part of a
legacy
and i i just um i admire the possibility
of a great legacy of
that that is bigger than either of the
fighters i think
with khabib he kind of um he's not as
concerned about legacy i think
right there's uh you're a promoter's
dream because you want the rematch
and the only thing that makes more money
than the rematch is the trilogy
you got to split the trip split the the
the rematch you hope conor wins and then
you have the trilogy fight
and you now you're all in yeah yeah i
can't get into khabib's
head but i know putin just the game the
entirety of it especially at the time
especially if it was
trump as president uh if
he was as president at the time and and
putin
and in russia and just
knowing how masterful connor is at like
because kano would would be a different
connor i think he would be a calmer
connor
like there would be a different uh like
because you don't want to be over the
top connor with the russian people
right no it's it's like uh
dangerous that was the episode
in the hotel in brooklyn yeah when um
some of the russian guys confronted uh
artem
and then conor came over it's not but
the danger of that i mean there is
the the element of just like real danger
and the real
it was almost of war it's uh i don't
know it's
it was like when when uh when chael
sonnen was talking so much smack it
maybe it was against vanderlei silva
i don't know it was one of those fights
where they they just didn't think he was
going to make it out of brazil yeah
yeah americans don't get it yeah
like people take some of that [ __ ] in
different parts of the world very very
seriously yeah
but that's what makes it beautiful
that's uh that's what makes a great
story and i think fighting is very much
about the stories
not just about the the the particular
outcomes of a fight or the skill set
matching or like
the chess of the of the fight it's also
about the story
of the greater like
context of societies of warring we're
like warring cultures
we're still we're still go we're we're
no longer can have
great big hot wars between nations
because of nuclear weapons this is our
wars that we can have
and uh you know in some sense i feel
robbed of the great war that could have
happened
it doesn't mean there aren't lots of
wars going on but yeah the big one is
not
gonna happen there's too much of a
balance of power with you know nuclear
weapons and technology and stuff
but it's not the end of war
no do you think there's always gonna be
war
i think there'll always be war
especially in underdeveloped parts of
the world
um isn't there always underdeveloped
relatively parts of the world
yeah i mean at some point though you'd
think i mean the way that
you know uh technology is expanding and
we're bringing technology
to weird parts of the world that you
wouldn't
uh think of as technologically advanced
the way that uh
the chinese are inhabiting certain areas
for mining purposes and things like that
i think underdeveloped parts of the
world will get developed quickly
i just wonder like what the nature of
that war might be it could be cyber
it could be all those kinds of things i
think in developed nations it's going to
be cyber i think that's probably the
next phase of war
but i mean i think you talk about parts
of the world like the middle east and
it's just still going to be
warring tribal factions we can't even
begin to understand what those
people are fighting about over there yet
yet everyone sitting in america on their
couch has an opinion
like you can't even begin to understand
it i i sure can't
yeah it's back to the principles
discussion when um
when when what's violated is much deeper
than just kind of um
anything we can even in a middle class
existence
can't even comprehend a lot of times
american soldiers will go to war because
that's what they're told to do and they
maybe they disagree with the orders and
maybe they agree with the orders but i
get a sense that people in the middle
east fighting
all believe in what they're fighting for
it's not it's not a thing where
they're told to go do it i believe
they're they really believe that what
they're doing is the right thing and
they're defending some sort of principle
are you generally optimistic about the
future
speaking of war of human civilization do
you think we'll
uh like
you know people talk about the fermi
paradox and asking
you know why haven't aliens visited us
if you believe they haven't visited us
you know one of the thoughts is that
there's a
kind of a great filter that intelligent
civilization reach a point
where it destroys itself naturally so
that's why we haven't seen them they
don't last very long
there does seem to be a kind of
we seem to be advancing faster and
faster and faster we keep developing
more and more powerful ways of
destroying ourselves in all kinds of
ways
not even you know just even to say
nuclear weapons alone
but there's all kinds of new ways
engineer pandemics
nanotechnology agi
all those kinds of things it's
it seems to be that uh the argument that
we
are going to destroy ourselves in some
kind of creative way very
shortly is uh not too crazy of an
argument to make
are you more optimistic or pessimistic
about the prospects of human
civilization in maybe the 22nd century
like is it possible that your generation
is the last generation to be alive on
earth
no but i wouldn't say that five
generations from now that won't be that
that could be true
i guess i think of it really selfishly
i'm a big believer that
when your time here on earth is over the
overwhelmingly vast majority of people
will be forgotten within 12 calendar
months
people with no family will be forgotten
sooner and so i don't give a lot of
thought to what will happen to earth or
mankind when i'm gone
i'm i give more thought to maximizing my
time here
now and i want to do it in a way where
uh i don't um
i'm not overtly hindering the future of
civilization or humankind
but i'm definitely taking a me first
approach to how i live on earth
do you have a philosophy behind why you
have or don't have kids
on this topic because for many people
when they have kids
there's a sense it's almost like a
genetic sense or something like that
where
all of a sudden you do start caring
about what happens five generations from
now
i mean i think i'm just too selfish
i mean i'm that's i think that's the
easy answer
like i i know that your whole life has
to change you know your
your your focus everything shifts and
just don't want to do and also like i
think that there's a level of
i i guess if i have to like really
unpack it there's probably a level
of um lack of hope
in the future like i don't think it's i
don't think the world and humanity is
going in the right direction
what does the right direction look like
i think the right direction
looks like people coming back together
in
in a more uh impactful
human way in person touching
feeling um talking face to face
so all the things you're describing is
what we had as you mentioned before when
you were like a teenager
yeah so the state of the world but
that's because your mind was formed then
it very well could be it very well could
be it's very possible that the virtual
reality worlds that we'll create
will be actually a much higher level of
existence in fact like
now we're getting we're moving slowly
away from
tribalism perhaps you could argue the
ideas of nations
and we're going we're moving into the
realm of ideas
and it could be a higher form of
existence where we're sort of
uh moving past the constraints of our
meat vehicles
into the space of our minds it depends
what you value because when you sit here
and you talk about it
you know and you're talking about these
things in these humongous levels
on these macro levels yeah and i don't
think a lot of people view it that way
i think a lot of people view it as like
what am i what kind of pizza am i
getting tonight
yeah like it's a it's a much different
outlook and sure
the the virtual world that's on the
horizon
i'm sure it's got benefits in what and
will help people but is it going to help
the things that you find valuable
like was it going to help commerce okay
sure is that the thing you find the most
valuable
is it going to help communication well
it'll help disseminating information
is it going to help explain the
information you're disseminating
probably not
is it going to hinder interpersonal
communication absolutely and those are
things i find valuable
interpersonal communication talking to
people like the
like it saddens me when i go into a
restaurant and there's five-year-old
kids who like you know slamming away on
an ipad and can't make eye contact with
anybody
or teenagers who don't say please and
thank you when they order from the
waitress like
that to me is wrong that shit's wrong
and
i don't know this for a fact but i do
attribute that to
you know using technology as a crutch
when we're raising
raising kids yeah you know i think those
are
those are things that i find valuable i
tried to empathize i mean i agree with
you as a person who grew up in a certain
age but like
uh prior to the internet i suppose uh
but or at least solidified the early
philosophies of the way i see the world
prior to the injury
during the time of aol let's put it this
way
uh what was your aim screen name i never
had one okay
dude i i was the last person i knew to
get a cell phone i was so
anti all that stuff because i just felt
like
i didn't want to be a part of it i did
not want to be a part of it i
i joined the underground forum about mma
in 2000 or 2001 when i first started
training
i think right at the tail end i got a
myspace but i didn't have any of that
stuff and i didn't want any of it
i don't know why i just was i was not
into it
i i felt like like what are the good
things that are going to come out of it
oh my i'm going to get my package in two
days instead of four days
does that make my life better i try to
uh i try to deeply empathize with a lot
of experiences of other people and like
one of the things
i love like the smell of paper books and
books in general
and early on this is like five years ago
i just gave away all my books
and i said you know i'm really going to
try to
fall in love with the books in the same
way i did before but
now with a kindle or not a kindle like
paper white whatever the ee
reader e-reader and uh i'm still not
there
but i've been kind of trying to fall in
love with that experience and
the same way i try to think like
teenagers are really into tick tock now
like making these short videos
i try to consider the possibility that
their existence will be a much happier
one than i've had
because of this kind of interaction it's
from my sort of skeptical perspective
it's like
the attention span is so short they
don't really deeply think or deeply
experience
things they construct a social layer
that they present to the world
and they work on creating this social
layer like
the presentation to the world much more
than really sitting alone with their
thoughts and the sadnesses and their
hopes and dreams and fears
and like working on the project that is
their
their own like actual person that exists
in this physical world
as opposed to working on the project of
a particular social platform but they
show
but like perhaps that project
like who cares who you are in the
physical space maybe
what you are is what your instagram
shows that's the more important project
to work on well what's reality is
reality perception is reality right so
how other people perceive this
constructed thing that's their reality
of you but is it your reality like that
i mean like we said earlier it's
what what you want how you want people
to see you
is very rarely in line with how you
really are or how you see yourself
and i mean i can remember being like a
13 year old kid and like when you go
through a bunch of you know weird
13 year old kid [ __ ] like sitting in my
room
like turning a red light on and
listening to like a sad record
and like you know trying to figure out
what's going on inside
sometimes you like it sometimes you
don't like it but i feel like
those experiences are lost on kids
constantly connected to a phone and like
you know i don't know what the remedy
for those situations is nowadays like i
don't know do they make a tick tock
video do they
do they blog about it did they you know
make a video or
nobody blogs anymore bro whatever man or
oh a video a story about oh this is what
happened to me and blah blah blah
blah does that actually help them work
it out or does it just create more noise
and more static on how to get to the
root of the problem and learn about
themselves
i don't know what future social networks
are exactly i do know
on a shallow level it does feel good
when somebody clicks like on something
i think that is more of a drug than an
actual deep
long-lasting fulfilling happiness but
perhaps there is a way to make a social
network that does lead to
long-lasting happiness that's somehow
detached from the physical
meat space i don't know but it feels
like you want to give that a chance
do you think when people are liking
things on social media
do you think there's just a group of
people an overwhelming majority of
people that are going to like whatever
you put out there they're clicking like
and then there's another section of
people that just constantly scroll and
like
scroll and like and scroll and like like
do you think
when you get a like on content you put
out that that like perhaps came from
someone who normally
doesn't like your content but like
you've just changed their mind
on something or you you've turned them
around on it i tend to think that when i
get
likes on social media those are just the
people that like all my [ __ ] no matter
what i say
like they probably don't even read it
like i could you know put the most
preposterous thing up there
and you're still gonna get a handful of
the same exact likes that's interesting
but i i tend to
the way i see likes you're kind of you
said multiple things
i think in one sense you see social
media as like a battleground of ideas
and like is it kind of indicate like the
best possible like is an indicator of
like
of the of you winning over somebody on
an idea and they really appreciate the
idea that's the best possible like
to me a like is just two strangers
smiling at each other
like like a moment of like like
i got you bro yeah i got you bro yeah
yeah like
fist bump like yeah we're in this
[ __ ] thing together
this whole thing doesn't make any sense
but we're in this together and
i yeah it's possible for likes to be
that i i don't
think the actual clicking of a like i
think social media at his best might be
that
where it's like i got you bro and it's a
large scale
as opposed to kind of uh this weird uh
like crazy pool of dopamine where
everyone's just
obsessed with this likes and likes and
and then the division drives
like more of this like weird anxious
engagement i think that's just the dark
version of it in the early days of
social media
i think you called it uh a battleground
of ideas but i think social media is
nothing but a battleground of fragile
egos
well but humans are fragile egos i mean
maybe but i think the people i think
particularly on social media
they're the most fragile like
would you be doing all the things you're
doing what would you be doing if you
weren't
um if you weren't podcasting
and posting the things you do on social
media
what would you be doing you'd probably
be much the same guy
right but i think that on social media
the fragile ego people what you see on
social media is not what they'd be doing
without social media
does that make any sense like you're
you're probably your mission is probably
somewhat congruent in your path
you're just utilizing social media but i
think a lot of people
social media has changed their path and
and now they're doing something totally
foreign to them and they're only
able to do it maybe because of social
media i think you're focusing on a
particular
moment in time of people in their
less great moments like in their less
great version of themselves
i think you're just focusing on the
masses struggling to
uh to become the best version of
themselves and then you
yeah sure for stretches of time whether
it's
days weeks or months you could be a
shitty person on the internet
i think you're
focusing on that and unfortunately
social media platforms
emphasize they love it when you're like
that when you're not doing great in your
own
in your own life because it increases
anxiety increases engagement
makes you more susceptible to an
argument and then really get pulled into
like conspiracy theories all that kind
of stuff
but the other side works too i think
there's also the people who are on
social media like
fronting like they're these positive
figures and like you know
going to the gym like whatever it is the
positivity that they spew out but in
real life they're the most negative
[ __ ] you've ever met in your life and
they're just so full of crap
and it's just you people playing to an
audience it's like you like you said
like they
it's like a politician sometimes like a
politician wakes up one day and they
decide
who's the group i can pander to the best
to get the most
likes equals votes yeah and it's the
same thing on social media people wake
up and
whether it's conscious or not what's the
group i can pander to
the best to get the most likes is it the
positivity motivated crowd
is it the woe was me crowd like what is
it who's going to give me the most likes
that's what i'll do i i don't know how
to argue against that i
guess it's it's uh it rings
true what you're saying but i just kind
of refuse to believe it
i guess i'm pandering to the optimistic
crowd
like i met with my marketing team and i
just feel that uh
uh love has the uh the best uh
what do you call it no i don't know
there's a lot of people that accuse me
of being like
exactly that which is like why are you
always being positive it's like
well because i i'd like to be that
yeah but i don't i wouldn't consider you
someone who panders
no but you know it i guess what i'm
saying is like
uh it's easy to say that everyone is
pandering
but like maybe they're just trying
i i do believe that social media
platforms could encourage people when
they're trying to be the best version of
themselves whatever that
is it could be like conor mcgregor
talking [ __ ] it could be just being
positive
it could be actually creating cool
things in this world um
putting out instructional videos for jiu
jitsu or like inspiring students to
competition all i don't know
all those kinds of things educational
content i i think that people are trying
like i i tend to believe that people
want to be
good like like they want to be
successful whatever that definition of
success is and they're kind of
struggling to do that and they're just
awkward at it at first
and like it's easy to focus on the
awkwardness and the
the stumbling around us people have that
and they start [ __ ] on each other
like
it's easy to kind of focus in on that
but i think that's just like
people you know white belts there's more
white belts in the world than there are
black belts but you gotta give them a
chance to kind of grow
i think on social media if you put your
stuff out there whatever your stuff is
your content your views or whatever
you let the chips fall where they may
like that's a different thing than being
like i'm gonna
i'm gonna tweak what i normally might
say and put it up this way because i
want these people to like it
and in terms i also think i have a
different
viewpoint than you do on people wanting
to be successful
i actually don't think that many people
want to be successful
i think people want to have the
appearance of wanting to be successful
but to be successful takes a shitload of
work and most people don't want to put
that work in
so they craft this persona of a person
who's trying really hard
but just can't catch the break or you
know these [ __ ] with
getting back on my grind you've never
been on a grind
you've been on the couch i so disagree
with you i get it i get it
you you that's your foil you enjoyed
that guy in the couch with the cheetos
that's you that's that's your motivation
but just own it be like
don't be like back on the ground be back
on the couch yeah
well you you you're like david goggins
who's like talking [ __ ] to the one guy
with the eating cheetos and in
in so doing inspires millions to like
to actually pursue their success i get
it but i just think that most people
really do want to be successful and are
like are trying to work hard and they
keep failing uh
so i mean but why is it why is it
continue i'm sorry to interrupt you
but like let's take a person who's
overweight yeah do you not think that
person wants to be skinny of course they
want to be skinny
they just don't want it enough to put
the pizza or the pie down and go to the
gym
they want it but they want it to be easy
of course they want to be skinny well of
course he wants it to be easy right and
of course
people people want to be successful but
do they want it enough
to do the work i don't think they do i
think the easy thing to do is to
to create a uh an outward facing
persona of the person who really wants
it and you get the same reward
from a lot of people as the person who
actually is successful
very few people differentiate from the
person who's found success
and and the person who's showing you how
they're trying to get success on social
media
people see that as the same i see i see
you're going after the marketing dollar
that represents the
the people that want to work hard yeah i
like it
uh you uh
started a podcast recently oh yeah
called which people probably from this
conversation can
i guess we didn't really talk about
politics much or the fact that you're a
business owner the fact that you're a
red-blooded american
and love this country uh uh america
we wouldn't really talk about that but
from the name of the podcast they can
probably infer it and the name is please
allow me good name uh
what have you learned from doing this
podcast
what's your hope of doing this podcast
for people should definitely
listen to you have a few episodes out
you're damn good at it
which is very interesting i'm sure
you'll evolve and change but
so this is like the early days i'm
curious to see where it goes
but what like what's your thinking
around it as a
as an intellectual putting your thoughts
out into the world
i think that one of the things that
covey did
um when we were all kind of in lockdown
was
as a business owner it made me take
stock of what's the future of brick and
mortar businesses
and i've always been reluctant to
be an online presence in any way just
because it's not my thing because i
believe that i'm a force of nature and
people need to experience me
right and uh the the few characters that
twitter has or faces not enough to
experience not enough
the force of nature there's john clark
oh yeah right i want you to feel
physically uncomfortable around me i've
just been three hours of me being
physically uncomfortable
i'm scared for my life uh and so i
thought that
that would be one of the ways in which i
could increase like i i came to the
conclusion that
with the the lockdown and potential
future lockdowns you know
uh in order to pay my mortgage and you
know my bar
tab and my grubhub's out of control
that i would need to find ancillary ways
to
doordash slash lex uh you don't want to
use grub pop grubhub sucks
they actually do doordash no i'm just
kidding just walk to your local
uh food or 7-eleven yeah and get and get
the food
you can order 7-eleven from door dash or
from post
code lex okay i'm sorry um
but anyway i thought it was like oh i
should probably increase a little bit my
online
presence and what would be a way to do
that that
would be fun for me and entertaining and
i thought well
a lot of people yourself included that i
know have done some podcasts and i find
uh that inspiring and i'm fortunate
enough to know a bunch of cool
[ __ ]
that you know i can talk to about a lot
of a wide range of topics
then they're starting to drop and
there's an aspect to which podcasting
does capture the force of nature
better in in the digital form podcasting
captures the force and nature of a human
being better than other mediums perhaps
yeah definitely there's that i i just
felt like
you know you know when it's midnight and
you're in the bar
and you get the sense that you know the
bar's gonna close in 90 minutes and you
think
you know not enough people have seen me
yet and maybe we should go to another
bar so more people can see me
yeah i feel like podcasting is like
is like that for me not enough people
have heard my thoughts and i feel like
my mom raised me to be a giver she
didn't want me to be selfish
and i have these thoughts that i think
that i think could be a waste if you
didn't give it to the world people seem
to really enjoy them
yeah i enjoy well while i've probably
been on my best behavior today on on
this episode of the podcast
so if you want the uh the uncensored
unfiltered
uh the full spectrum that the force of
nature is john clark
you go to do you go you go to the
podcast you funny enough
i think you're drinking throughout most
of the podcast yeah yeah
tequila so they only last like an hour
because you seem to like
i'm guessing that you just lose it one
hour like it's like cinderella turns
into a frog or
whatever one of the things i'm learning
is um
sometimes you have great conversations
when you're drunk and sometimes you
don't like i was
i went into it with the right drunk edit
sober mentality
yes hemingway hemingway yes but
turns out that uh
sometimes you don't have that much to
edit when you're super shit-faced
and so uh i've been scaling that back a
little bit
and what do you mean exactly by that
like where does it go wrong when you're
drunk i'm curious about that because
uh it gets you especially when you have
a personal relationship with the person
that you're talking to
rather than trying to put some ideas on
display for other people to hear and
maybe talk about
you wind up just having like a
conversation with your bro about inside
jokes and things like that and it's like
it's not that interesting no one wants
to like watch you know
go to a bar and watch two people at the
sitting there getting drunk and talking
to each other is different
than listening to uh like strong
discourse
yes one interesting thing as a fan of
joe rogan i'm a fan i've been a fan of
joe rogan for a long time and he has his
friends over
a lot right and there there's a aspect
to those three four or five hour
conversations that i really enjoy
there's a magic to those i think he
taught the world that those kinds of
long-form conversations can work
the what you forget is joe rogan is a
comedian
his friends are also celebrities like
they know what it's like to be on the
mic they know
there is a challenge to actually having
your friends on the microphone
like they're they've never this is the
first time they've been on a microphone
yeah and that's actually what you've
been doing which is a very
interesting experiment and uh
you find that some are more awkward than
others like they're trying to find like
what do i do with this kind of thing why
why do you not talk to strangers why did
you go with people that you're actually
no so the simple answer is the people
that i selected are both interesting and
i thought would be good at talking
but then i noticed the thing you just
mentioned my buddy paul did the first
one and paul's a wild man
and if you went out with paul he can
talk about a bazillion
topics to a certain to to a significant
uh level of depth right he's got a good
understanding and he's got a unique
perspective on a lot of things
um and i think
he was the first guy invited on my
podcast
and it was almost like
he was on a little bit less than natural
about it and then by the time he
loosened up with some drinks
he was it just we were all shit-faced
there's
there's a phase shift though totally
yeah totally
and so he's gonna come back on and he'll
be more comfortable with it and uh and
it'll probably be awesome because he's a
great person to talk to
um i had my friend dave on who's a
restaurant and a musician
that that one will be released pretty
soon but yesterday i had a guy on who
you might really enjoy listening to
who's a friend of mine his name is mark
clem
he's an endurance athlete and he's been
compared
he's been called the white dave goggins
and um
he talks about like those comparisons
and what he hates about it
and the various events and stuff and
he's just a guy who's just always kind
of like natural
and like i knew he'd be great to get on
the podcast and um
so i started with friends who i thought
could handle it
and who also are just really interesting
people
and uh and i i did it so that i could
also establish a level of comfort
because it was a new thing for me
and they i knew that they wouldn't
really give a [ __ ] what i was doing and
be like hey this is cool i'm going over
jc's house we're gonna drink some
tequila and talk [ __ ] there's just gonna
be a microphone there this time
i mean it's amazing what you're doing
the freedom of it i mean you're not
currently doing
advertisements or any of that kind of
stuff you're just exploring your voices
one of the mediums that you're just
trying it out my 11 subscribers know
what i'm about you're 11 subscribers
it's in the double digits yeah uh
for both you and i do you have advice
for me as a podcaster
and for yourself as a podcast like if
you if you were to think like you're
gonna do
say i mean who knows but say you do a
thousand more episodes
right like imagine a world where that
that your life continues in that
direction that this is like
a little parallel to like for me this
thing is like a little side hobby but
it's also
one that's deeply fulfilling um so not
just from a
business perspective which is not the
way i think about it i just think from a
life
human perspective it's i probably
wouldn't have this kind of conversation
with you off mike
like this long this deep this attentive
there's something really fulfilling
about these conversations so
what advice would you have for me what
advice do you have for yourself or have
you not introspected this
that deeply oh i have a lot i have
advice i think the
first advice i would give to you is i
think you should uh have me on more
often
yes yeah that's
first first and second is go on your
podcast and uh
well i would say i would say you come on
my podcast when you're ready
yeah when you feel like the product that
i'm putting out
uh would benefit from your presence and
vice versa
not not as a not as a favor to a bro
but at the right time i i do sense
actually it's an interesting
there's a dance to it which is uh like
joe i recently did like joe rogan
had a conversation with me on this
podcast there's a very specific kind of
thing
where you you're helping each other out
yeah but the timing on that has to be
right right you know like
uh right if that makes any sense you're
like supporting each other
it doesn't make sense it doesn't it
doesn't make a difference you would
think
right because it's it's just people
talking it doesn't matter what
microphones
but it changes things it does and
there's an order to the guests that i've
had on
and the next guest that i'll have on
will be a
a friend we have in common and we'll be
talking about teaching how to teach
different styles of teaching and what
you're teaching all these other things
do you mind saying who oh sean fisher
and um
i think there's an order to it's not
scientific but it's based on my gut
is it uh astrologically based uh
what do you mean it's not scientific
you're you're god so you have a sense uh
like joe rogan for example tries to do
left right he tries to alternate like
this this gut feeling
of like these bins of people and he
tries to alternate
world views that's interesting like he
kind of so
he doesn't feel like it that like it
shake it constantly shakes him it's it's
more about him
like constantly pulls him in multiple
directions about like
how he sees the world and that keeps him
balanced
that keeps the conversation kind of
exciting that's interesting i i did it
in a way where
i knew paul was going to be wild and we
might get a little out of control and
like have some technical
hiccups along the way and then my friend
jake who's a ceo of a pharmaceutical
company
that was very timely because uh you know
he was able to speak to vaccines and
that was kind of scientific
flavored yeah and what i learned
listening back on that
is like i learned for myself about uh
i wasn't asking the next level questions
to really draw out great answers and
part of it is
uh i you're simultaneously hanging out
with a bro but also i was trying to
learn something and i didn't learn what
i wanted to learn
and that's my fault because i didn't ask
the questions he's an expert in that
field he doesn't know that i'm
an absolute [ __ ] when it comes to
that stuff and so i didn't do a good job
and if i don't know it that means
the thing i was trying to tease out of
him no one who is going to listen is
going to learn that either
yeah so i learned that um and then i had
the one with soap on which i thought
was was pretty good um there's a
wrestler there's also a farmer
right and he's a social worker and kind
of humble and
and thoughtful yeah thoughtful
thoughtful guy like slower
not a wild man that kind of thing not a
wild man in the sense that i'm wild but
he does preach this
this philosophy of being more wild like
being
in touch with nature nature that that
that kind of work
right right right and then my buddy dave
he came
on um you know because i love music
and i wanted to talk a lot about music
and he's one of the most knowledgeable
people
about music that i know and he's got a
restaurant coming up and
i thought my buddy mark clem being an
endurance athlete like when you hear
some of the
i didn't even know these things existed
that this [ __ ] kid did he's out of
his mind
and you know i think shawn and i will
have probably the most intellectual
conversation that i'll have had on my
podcast
to date and so there's a little bit of
alternating there but
um you know i did it that way
uh so that there's a guy there's a gut
feeling behind oh so that what is there
where are you going do you know where
you're going uh
i'm i don't have a destination but i
want to
i want to see it to its end whether
that's
uh it gets somewhere of its own volition
or it takes on a new life at some point
and then i know how to drive it where it
needs to go
i think the advice i have for both of us
is um i think i
need to no
i don't think so i think for you i see
an inner turmoil
i see a storm that bruises you because i
feel like
there's a concern for what you're saying
and is it gonna get
is it gonna is it gonna lead to
uh negative feelings towards you or the
thing that you're doing
and i feel like
we're different people and i have such
an easier time saying [ __ ] off to
everybody
and that's a liberating thing but it
also
can can keep me from achieving the thing
that i want to achieve
because i'm so flippant with opinions
that i don't listen to them and let them
direct me when they should there's a
balance
let me push back on that please i think
you you believe that about yourself and
nevertheless your social media presence
indicates otherwise if i were to be very
harsh you're like one of those
you know mentally strongest character
wise people i know
and yet on social media you don't put
your face to the world
no one of the reasons you sense the fear
in me
which exists i of course want to let go
of it
is because i put my face on like my my
name on
things and so when i say something
stupid
it it hurts when people did say
like look that guy said something stupid
and so there's a fear of saying
something stupid
in all of his different forms uh like
of being my lesser so it's the same
feeling i have in competition of like
of losing not just losing losing doesn't
matter it's
embarrassing myself i like losing uh
being the lesser version of myself
and when you put yourself out there in a
full way i think you would i
i would venture to say you're also
because you like said you you don't
you wouldn't give yourself that advice i
feel like you're also afraid of standing
behind some of the ideas
because right now you're doing guerrilla
warfare you're you're free to
to uh to be uh to say things
to speak your mind from the sidelines
but the moment you're standing and like
when people can throw [ __ ] at you
i feel like uh you haven't faced that
far yet you've been like avoiding that
fire i'm not sure
maybe i'm projecting no to a degree
you're right i think like a big thing
for me was putting like
ads on for like our our jiu jitsu online
uh
like um curriculum that was a big thing
uh for me because for several reasons
like in the climate of
everyone under the sun having a you know
a jiu jitsu tutorial online
and social media not social media
necessarily but forums specifically that
uh critique and [ __ ] the bed one thing i
have not done that i've thought about
doing and probably
you're right in your analysis of it is
i've not gone the way that
i do see you on things like reddit and
say hey reddit i'm doing this
like i could easily go to red and say
hey reddit uh i got this website up here
here's a sample video whatever the [ __ ]
people do on there but yeah you're right
i haven't done that
and part of it might be because i i
i know also if i get suckered in for one
second into the negativity
i'm going to become an online warrior
and i don't want to be that person
so yeah you're probably self-aware about
that i mean one of the things
i've early on decided is like i'm just
gonna be
i've always really enjoyed being
positive so i'm going to make sure
i stay that way and when there's
negativity it's like
i'm not just ignoring it i'm literally
just returning it with positivity
i like no i probably am the same way as
you most people are
with with egos you get you want to
become the warrior against the
negativity and
uh like like many wars there's no
winning
right there's no winning that was posted
online especially on the internet and uh
so in that sense that's that's been a
journey to try to
to face the fire of the negativity
and it's not actually that bad it sounds
like very dramatic there's not many
people that are negative but
it's like when you put advertisements so
you put your face on an instructional or
something like that right
it just there's an aspect to it which
you're being a salesman you're being a
gimmicky thing right it just feels wrong
and people will point out look that guy
is a fraud like it's fake look he's
trying but those people are going to be
out there and if you're like
trying to do your best trying to be
authentic and not trying to like
be a a snake oil salesman
and being like the shady kind of
salesman um
i think they keep you honest they keep
you being the most
authentic self and podcasting is like
the best medium because you're being
real those
one hour plus that you put out there
that's like
real john that's not a
like people people fall in love with
that and that that's that the beautiful
aspect of podcasting is
there's no long form doesn't give any
possibility for you not to be authentic
right
and that's why it's a magical medium the
the tough thing
is you're not you know popularity
takes time right now popularity and so
like you should shouldn't be doing it
for that reason
and i don't it's not the thing that
really uh drives me yeah
is there three books technical fiction
philosophical that had an impact on you
like is there books that you kind of
return to that you enjoy
and never had you know you find profound
in some way i would say like
probably the thing i read is in one of
emerson's essays that i read at a
you know point in my life where i needed
that type of thing
and i read self-reliance and you know
he's got a ton of good essays but i
thought self-reliance was probably
the most impactful to me um
you know i've read later in life like a
handful of
you know existential authors and they're
all great
but at the time a lot of it has to do
with timing
and when i read self-reliance and it was
about the individual
uh that was really good and made it was
uh
impactful there's also a book called uh
jonathan livingston seagull
by richard uh richard bach i think and
um
it's kind of along the same lines it's
about this seagull who you know wants to
break conformity and
learn to fly and do all these other
great things and so it's a very short
read so if people are interested in that
that's good
uh the book which i was
lucky enough to read before the movie
ever even came out
which is just a a pleasure of mine was a
american psycho
just from a writing standpoint yeah i
found that the writing was
was awesome uh brett easton ellis who's
the author of that and several other
books who have like intertwining
characters
uh he's a new england prep school guy
and so a lot of like the stories and a
lot of the
the visuals uh rang true for me
and anyone who can write four pages of
prose on like a huey lewis album i mean
kudos to you
and i also would say no one will do this
but i would at some point
read as much of one of the big three
religious texts
as possible it really gives you
perspective there's so many overlapping
stories in the in
in of religious texts and then the way
that they're
written gives you a unique perspective
on
different people uh throughout the world
and you know if you're a roman catholic
maybe
don't read the bible read one of the
other texts and that would be an
interesting take
but i'm embarrassed to say that first of
all i've never read the bible which is
embarrassing to say it's like i read a
bunch of stuff about the bible not the
bible itself and the same
not equating them but i haven't read
marx
directly i haven't read mineconf by
hitler directly
and it feels like sometimes because you
think like it's better to read stuff
about the books but ultimately you want
because like the analysis will be better
in the texts
that uh followed it but there's value to
actually reading like the actual words
uh yeah there's this power in the words
that uh there's a reason why like the
bible
is one of the most impactful books ever
you know and it's it's in it's in those
words
and it's uh of value to return to those
words the communist manifesto is truly
frightening if you read it in
in like modern context
it's worth reading yeah we're three
years so is mineconf
not obviously well uh it's not obvious
but
it is not very well written uh but all
the ideas that led to the evil that is
hitler
are all in there which is uh fascinating
to think about because
probably some of the world leaders at
the time should have probably read the
books he he outlined everything he's
going to do
you've mentioned offline you mentioned
an emerson quote i really like
so let's try to end on this powerful
quote
it's easy in the world to live after the
world's opinion it's easy and solitude
to live after your own
the great man is who in the midst of the
world keeps with perfect sweetness the
independence of solitude
what does this quote mean to you uh it's
kind of uh reinforces the idea that
you're here to live your life and that
even when people are trying to
influence you or
comment on the decisions that you make
for your life you should have the
strength to stick by
living your life the way you want to
live it that
there's one immutable truth for you and
it doesn't apply to everyone
and so people who um
people who frown upon
or judge the way that you live because
it's not
air quotes conventional uh their opinion
should not be something that impacts the
choices that you make
you're in a relationship now yes is that
deeply meaningful
or is it are you ultimately still alone
is this are you still just a man
in the cold of the of the life that is
suffering
no i'm a man who's warm nestled in a
bosom
i don't think there's a better way to
end uh john
uh you're a friend you're my coach
i'm sure we'll talk many more times in
the future thanks for wasting all your
time with me today thanks brother thanks
alex i had an awesome time hope to be
back soon
thanks for listening to this
conversation with john clark and thank
you to our sponsors
theragun the device i use for
post-workout muscle recovery
magic spoon low-carb keto friendly
cereal that i think is delicious
eight sleep a mattress that cools itself
and gives me yet another reason
to enjoy sleep and finally cash app the
app i use to send money to friends
please check out the sponsors in the
description to get a discount and to
support this podcast
if you enjoy this thing subscribe on
youtube review it with five stars and
apple podcast
follow on spotify support on patreon or
connect with me on twitter
at lex friedman and now let me leave you
with some words
from miyamoto musashi think
lightly of yourself and deeply
of the world thank you for listening and
hope to see you
next time
you